Oh my gosh, we're going just no intro, no intro at all.
We're just going live.
Well, I am very nervous.
Uh, I am just, ah, I'm so nervous.
Hello, everyone.
Hello.
Oh, okay.
Let me adjust.
Let me have a push to mute button.
I didn't set that up for my key bind.
Well, toggle me.
Um,
okay okay i have toggle mute okay okay i am oh thank you everyone i'm so nervous oh my god i've been okay so for those who don't know yes i what happened joki how are you wait where am i wait a minute where am i i'm not even on this list what happened where did i go i'm in the lobby There you go.
Yeah, okay, there you go.
Those who are like, wow, Tokyo, why are you flat?
The last time we saw you, you were in silver.
Yes, so I went on and so I went on a seven-game win streak and got gold.
And then after that, I went on, and last night I played rank last night, and I went on a seven-game win streak, and then I stopped.
at gold four um and because i was like oh fuck i'm hard and then like my win street was god and then i got like that was hard stuck gold four and then uh i went to bed at like i played like rink off stream for four like three to four hours i think three to four hours um after marvel rivals and oh yeah sorry sorry i'm so nervous that oh it's okay it's okay i'm pretty pretty sure i'm not on stream yet sorry i was so nervous and then um i sent message to nephew and big braid i was like i did it i got to go over for now i'm hard stuck gold for and i was like i don't think i'm gonna get plaid though and then i went to bed uh i went to bed and then i woke up and then i got an eight game win streak and then i got the plaid never mind yeah never mind i locked in and then yeah after after i got my seven game one streak to so uh gold four i went to and i was hard stuck old four for a couple of matches and i stopped at gold five i was like i almost swear i was like i'll do that whatever i'll stay
here like i don't care about that and i in the morning i woke up and it was like 12 and i was like i was like i was like 11.
I was like, you know, I'll warm up a little bit.
Um, I don't want to like focus all my time just playing.
So I'll just, I'll play a little bit.
And I went on an eight game win streak and now I'm flat.
Now I'm in flat.
And then I'd sent the screenshot.
I sent the screenshot to like nephew and big bird.
And I was like, look, are you proud of this?
Like, you know, like I'm a child.
I'm like going up to like mommy and daddy.
I'm like, look, I got, I got so proud.
Oh, you of me and then they're like we're so proud of you sweetie and i'm like yippee i was like wait what did i say it's like oh yeah it's like i don't think i can get to plaque though never mind oh wait yeah let me show you guys let me show you guys my tweet to nephew um give me a sec i i saved this so i'm like stuttering because i'm honestly like i'm really nervous i don't know i put too much have fun i'm gonna try and have fun that's the key we're all just here to have fun here you go
this is what i said to like by the way um three days i learned honda in three days chat like i haven't touched street fighting um for a year since the last slam and then uh and then and then you very surprised like i peaked and like my highest rank i've ever got was basically flat because when i was on saying keep are we waiting for anything by the way we're not oh no one's like holding up right i'm not sure i don't know they're on the screen yapping right now i think they're just introducing about the teams yeah i am pretty sure capcom fighters is the stream yeah yeah yeah yeah they're just introducing the teams right now uh okay okay cool oh yeah i think i need to reset my discord because my push to mute isn't working give me a sec oh should we like stream together something like that or what i'm on youtube i'm down if you don't want to all right you guys i'm gonna reset my discord so i can yeah i need to share chat sounds fine uh wait so how does it work with so many people does one
person has to like send a link i have to do like admin so i can have my push to mute on which is very frustrating run as admin All right, here we go.
Oh, but I'm like so nervous right now.
Just because like it's been a while since I've been in a tournament setting.
So I'm trying not to be too nervous.
I have to send the invitations.
Are we not all here?
What were we waiting for?
We were waiting for them to finish yapping.
Oh, yeah, I was going to say I thought we were all in the survey.
Wait, are you not in the...
Are you not in the lobby?
No, I'm in.
I'm in.
Okay.
Doki Bird.
Nephew.
I think I invited the correct people.
I'm also just going to post a link here as well.
Yeah, I think the link is better.
Oh, that link doesn't work.
Wait, this one shouldn't?
It doesn't.
click on it i restarted my discord and now my overlay doesn't work it's okay i can click on the thing everything's going wrong there i go on here oh no everyone no now they can't react hi guys hello hello i'm so nervous me too ma'am yeah it'll be everyone's nervous uh is so nerve-wracking I'm setting the pace wait a second that coach are you practicing I don't know why why isn't it working I'm I'm intimidating her you're you're helping me in there's no way there's no way you're helping her warm up man oh man bro oh wait I think he's gonna start now I just want to say that for twitch con when uh i helped sk warm up because we're on the opposite side of the brackets and then uh sk and then in our first five games i beat husk and i was feeling pretty good and then i went on stage and she cooked me two zero i helped her it's okay guys i broke it it happens i don't know how to fix it
I guess It can just wait in training mode I reset it Yeah Like would I just be facing them then or No you wouldn't be facing them Oh there you go You can join my training room if you want I did it You know like that It's good because if we take these training rooms then you know that picture of like the cat like this cat person cries like we need to hog every trading room the moment we can just sit down with a spire like the black spire scribbles everywhere can i use it be like oh i'll be done in a sec and then you just like wait until it's good i'm kicked out oh yeah let me take this picture off the screen are you lagging a little bit you're like skipping yeah but i can't tell uh but yeah i i got oh no i got uh i'm not lagging i got no no but you're like you're like skipping you guys see that i i got better i improved yes yeah we're going against brian i'm supposed to be able to react yeah i i yeah you should be able to react here
three days three days of honda three days of honda and i got to plat i don't know how so good i'll turn down oh do you think so okay because i get does he have to do the dpm okay or is it just a button let me know let me know i turned down prorodon and feisty let me know if it's better sorry i'm like really nervous no i don't want to leave don't
ah sorry sorry everyone I haven't been this nervous in a long time.
I think it's because, like, I didn't expect myself to climb this high on Honda.
So, like, I'm like, bro, okay, one of my mods was, like, scouting for me.
And apparently one of the players was labbing against me for two to three hours today.
Like, she was labbing against Honda for two to three hours.
what I'm not even the best I'm not even the best player in the bracket if anything the Aki's the best player in the bracket on this is like why are you laughing yeah or like anti-shimmy as well which is like if they shimmy you just like move back but like that's the oh my god and okay okay apparently I was talking about a different person but like I have to keep worrying about about my jp but like oh my god why is everyone laughing against me i'm just playing rake i also love this i don't think i've only had one hour to laugh against my opponents because i just wanted to play i was playing rake i was like i feel like i was just gonna get bad habits because i don't know like exactly the end the way your play styles are i don't even know oh are we starting
dog nephew.
Okay.
Yeah, I will.
I need a yeah, I don't know.
I'm nervous.
But don't be nervous.
You got it.
No pressure.
We're all watching you.
You're the first one we're all watching.
Okay.
I shouldn't give her too much pressure.
What are wait, which one is oh wait, okay.
Oh, wait, she's playing.
She's fighting bra pro.
Oh, she's not, she's not.
No, she's, She's fine.
She's fine.
I believe.
Oh, I believe.
I've always believed in my team.
Oh my god, look at her go.
What the heck?
Whoa.
Oh, no.
Oh, yes!
Yeah!
I've always believed.
You can probably try weaponry some more.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I don't know why I got my own head today because like I don't know.
I think it's because I I got too high of a rank I messed up.
I why did I why did I climb the plat
Oh nephew down a little kid why I should have stayed baby
down okay and so i'm like extra nervous when you have him quarter just watch for the jump outs too it's because like but i mean you're smoking him so yeah you did it now we're gonna do it again okay that's right true swap characters brawl pro he got nerfed i don't you know that should have played meta be a meta slave like me all
I'm saying is you should have been a meta slave oh my gosh I spoke too soon okay I don't want to jinx I don't want to jinx I want jinx here I'm not jinxing okay but like He's meta in my Elo.
The moment I fight Diamond Players, it was over for me.
That's why I'll never get to dive.
That's why I'll never climb up.
The thing that's bad is because I because like I Oh no Oh no Oh yeah!
Yeah, I know I'm nervous.
It's because I'm nervous.
Yeah, that's true.
I don't want to do flowcharts, guys.
I told, I literally told my coach want to play the easiest character that's most abusable in lower elo that's all i want i'm not here to learn combos i'm here to learn more moves like a pokemon all right oh god oh god oh no no not the not the grapple in modern that would have done half of that in HP.
Oh, that's so scary.
Because one, one grapple and it's like over.
Now I know how they fell.
Oh my god.
Oh, let's go.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Oh, she.
Yeah.
Let's go.
i mean that's that's kind of amazing what a comeback i'm trying i'm trying oh my yes that's it right 20 points what what did you say was that yeah it was 20.
no you're you're 20 dokey i'm 20.
yeah dokey's at 20.
no why why would you do this you get it you get it you're better you could have Oh, okay, okay, my bad.
Why did you tell me that?
Yeah, next match, you're 10 for sure.
You're literally better.
I'm going to lose.
Now, because if I lose, it's Nephew's fault.
You're literally so much better.
Like, don't even worry about it.
You too, Emily.
He's right.
I will.
I caught this.
I'm 20.
If we win, we get 20 points.
Oh, my God.
Dragon Ball.
Oh my god.
That's why I'm like, what do you beat up 20?
Okay.
Oh no.
I am like, um, it's very admiring that this person, uh, Shumi, Shumi, Shuh, Shuh?
Shuh minions?
Decide to learn JP.
Because of, you know, I looked at him for five seconds and I was like, no JP.
Oh, yeah.
I think you can throw her more.
Oh, okay.
That was good.
Nice round, Emily.
You got this.
Good round, good round.
Yeah.
I'm trying not to get my nerves.
I wish I didn't know I was 20.
No.
That looks so annoying to play against.
I feel like in, um, I feel, I feel like when you're up close to him, you can't really do much.
Because like, majority of his stuff is on range.
Let's go!
You're cooking!
Yeah, the moment like, you run up to the old man, you You can just beat him up.
I see the pressure.
Just beat up the old man.
Huh?
I'm actually so nervous, guys.
I think after the first game, I should be fine.
Because after the first game, I got like, you know, I got the initial game.
It's just the first, it's always the first game, you know, like, because they get the initial Oh, like, what's it called?
The jitter bugs gone.
Um, yeah.
Whoops.
Yeah, the nerves gone.
Oh.
No.
Whoa!
Oh my god, that was so cool!
You go for more button dry rushes when you're close.
Yeah, the tournament jitters.
I'm just gonna abuse my moves until it stops working.
Because, I don't know.
Because all characters counter me in this tournament.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
My team are, like, gamers.
And then there's me.
I'm baby.
Don't look at my rank.
My rank doesn't indicate anything.
I'm still baby.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
That looks...
That looks so annoying.
Oh!
You saw a longer meter.
Wow!
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
He's so annoying to play against.
What?
What the heck was that move?
Oh no, she's burned out.
That's not good.
You see, when I'm on Honda, when I'm burned out, mine's a bait.
I don't know if this can be good Bro,
this is so annoying I don't ever want to get out of plat I don't want to ever leave All good, all good You just have to throw him instead of going for your Out of light Oh my
god Observe, I'm observing old man oh nice that was a good drive i hate how people adapt in this game we should have a one and done tournament no adapting is just pure skill
adapting is not a skill
no i feel like she just keeps walking like what am i You can just walk forward and do your crouch medium.
Okay.
One try, no adapting.
Adapt on the fly.
Why do you need to have two games you adapt on the fly as you move?
If you need to think about how to counter your opponent afterwards, you've lost.
That's okay.
Do you like it?
cowards.
Jesus Christ.
You adapt while you, like I said, you adapt while you play.
Oh, Jesus.
God damn old man with his sticks.
Yeah!
Okay.
Oh.
That's bad.
I always get to use up all your meter just to block JP.
Yes, no, yes, no.
Okay, yeah, that's annoying.
Nice.
Oh, that was a good counter.
Oh my god, that was too close.
Oh my god, Emily, you were amazing.
You're crazy.
Dude, how did you ever come?
level two oh no you're like the fact that you block that level two you're amazing i don't know what happened better than me but it looked really cool my ass okay guys i'm sorry for if i we might lose 20 points yeah you are literally yeah you are literally better no i don't know i don't i don't know she was she was laughing against me for three hours out today it doesn't matter man oh okay okay block it you got uh i hope she doesn't know my first move
i think they don't want you to start yet oh okay i guess i wait yeah
it's just first game jitters after the first game i'll be fine
there's no way she'll know my first move
yeah she's like pre-adapting what a cow
oh my heart's beating so if i have a harm on it right now it is beating so fast right now it's always been like that for all the say the say jam slams my heart has always like the first game is always the most though always the most like scary for me i see clutched it we're all gonna win our matches yes yeah yeah all of us yeah me too you got it frodan just throw them in every way that you know how okay oh this is a first of three by the way what what the best five best five what what what what no we shall know my first right guys wait is it only like the person with two x points yeah the 20 point matches three out of five oh wait my controller's not working can you tell them to pause my controller wait what my controller dc'd oh what oh yeah i think she she's waiting for you wait my controller is not
it actually dc'd i'm gonna restart my game
can you tell them that i'm gonna restart my game oh yeah i'm telling you okay oh my god it's so weird it was working all the other times until i got in the lobby What controller do you use?
I use a leverless.
It was working this morning.
I was practicing with it.
Don't come.
OK, I'm going to restart.
I don't know what.
I got in the lobby, and then there was the game.
The controller was like, guess I won't play?
All good.
All right, I'm restarting.
I was wondering why I couldn't skip my cutscene.
I was just like, what?
they still don't know my first move because i didn't use it that's true you know theirs yeah yeah yeah i know theirs i know exactly what i'll do like mine game i'm gonna pull out too oh man my controller is not working too that's weird yeah oh my god my controller didn't oh no i hope my controller is okay Okay.
Oh, come on.
Huh?
What?
I don't understand.
Um.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, it's working.
It's working.
All right, let's go.
Okay.
Okay, it's working now.
You see that invite still?
Yeah, I got the invite.
I'm just getting in.
so I got really scared.
Oh.
Okay, it's working now.
That was weird.
That was very scary.
Okay.
I got it.
Okay, yeah, it's working.
Let's go, Donkey.
You got this.
Cooker.
They want to know my first move.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
All right.
Um.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Let's keep doing that.
Nice.
Okay.
I messed up my input.
My heart is beating very fast.
No worries.
Oh, that was a good try though.
Oh.
Fine.
You can try a DI her too just doing that.
Or I do this.
Oh, you can just do that too.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, my hands are shaking.
Let's go.
My hands are shaking.
Oh.
What the fuck?
They'll never expect my next move!
Let's go!
What would I
do next?
What would I do next?
Oh wait.
Who would have thought she knew?
Oh.
What would I do next?
Oh, okay, never mind.
Oh.
Oh no.
Oh, that's fine.
Yeah, I didn't think she'd use that.
I think your medium auto combo would go here if you wanted to just try and do that one.
Oh, I could do that.
There's like one more hit there.
Yeah, 20 points!
Oh, my God.
You're my goat.
One more game.
One more?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
One more.
Okay, I spoke too soon.
I spoke too soon.
Wait, she left.
I think maybe they thought it was over, but they have only one more.
So my chat was like, I'm low-key getting mad watching this.
If it works, it works, guys.
That's how I got to plat.
I fully agree.
I'm not here for honor.
It doesn't even matter, man.
It's not what I'm saying.
Honor, it's about winning.
Well said.
japan awaits
here's a reason why i picked honda for this elo
oh my god please don't tell brian don't tell him don't tell her i only know the left side
when we're in the when we're in the in the home the home team we're always player one so thank god okay okay wait and then when we're on the away team we're always player two yeah oh no oh no guys i did not practice the other side a good thing good thing headbutt still works on the right side thank you guys they'll never know what i'm gonna use yeah that's right oh shumimi's in canada did that change something oh was it laggy yeah
I was like, like, I feel like when I quickly want my super to come out, like, it doesn't work if there's a little laggy, or maybe I'm just bad.
And I've, it's Eastside Canada, it's like, there you go.
Nice.
What would I use?
Oh.
Oh no, I, I jumped.
That's fine.
It doesn't really do that with damage.
Oh, oh, it's fine
Oh, what the fuck Okay, there, yay Yeah, 20 points Oh, 20 points Oh, my god That is true, you were cooking on the right side I did it, she put me on the right side And I still made it out
Okay, we got 40 points then Hold on Alright, we're chilling Whatever happens, it doesn't matter anymore 50 points we're about to oh that's true that's true 50 is a nice number they will definitely 50 i believe in you dad yeah we can do it try to screw us over by practicing i have no nephew actually sent me with the os because if i lose i know exactly who to blame someone i'm not gonna say who but someone warmed up my opponent yeah she learned some new combos that would have been my
I think my heart was beating too fast that game.
I feel that.
The hardest iron match of my life.
I feel like everything you know when you go into a match like that was like some states in it and stuff.
Like, yeah.
The first like 30 seconds of that, I dropped my headbutt and that was the only move I know.
I was like, how do I mess up the only move I know?
You're the nerves, man.
Yeah.
No, guys, my heart was beating so fast.
Like, it still is.
It's still beating so fast right now.
I think when my controller just connected to us, just like, oh, no.
Kill her.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
It's flowchart time.
It's flowchart.
Oh, nice.
Whoa.
Learn that flowchart.
I told you, they never expect the first move.
The first move is always like, what would she do next?
What would she keep doing next?
Okay, okay.
She's talking a lot now, so you guys should me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So unexpected, I know.
They'll never expect it.
I like how Nephi was like, Or maybe I'll do this.
Surely she won't keep spamming headbutt, right guys?
Yeah, this is more, this is definitely, I was not playing Street Fighter.
I was playing my own game.
You have
to change it.
I do have to because this is just the group stage.
It's not even playoffs.
That's the scary part.
Like, what if they start adapting?
Oh, no, guys.
Okay.
What if they start adapting?
Please sweep.
Yeah, follow that flow chart.
Your lift punishes are insane right now, bro.
Okay.
Your lift punishes are crazy.
Yeah.
Pull up that flow chart on your other monitor if you need to.
Oh, my gosh.
Whoa.
What I noticed though is that what's her name?
She burns up so fast.
So all I have to do is she uses her burn.
You guys think I use burn up fast?
She uses her burn up faster than me.
So all I had to do was just spam it.
Like.
Oh yeah, she blocked it.
Oh Yeah, this combo burns you out so fast That's why I was like think I I thought I was I thought I was like I'm trying freaked up freaked up because of my brain up
I'm trying this I'm trying guys I'm trying so hard to make sure I don't curse I
because I don't even know which team is like the scariest team it must be so tilting to watch how I was playing in the main broadcast I wonder like people don't know who I am and they're like what the heck is she doing yeah that medium store you can always punish if it's like too close no I am my arm match is the first one He showed.
I was, yeah, I was the perfect Honda.
I was rage beating.
Head button DI, this is Street Fighter 6.
I told you, no one ever expects the first move.
Oh shit, sorry.
That's fine.
Oh, I had her.
That's all good.
Oh man, nice.
Oh my god, you got it anyway.
Oh my god, let's go!
You're so good!
Holy crap!
You're crazy.
Oh my god.
50 points, let's go!
I broke my wrist for you guys.
Oh my god, let's have a show match.
We still need it for the other matches, man.
Oh, that's true.
Oh, some wrist exercises.
Yeah, yeah.
coach riddles and you but like i need that and you yeah your with punishes were insane i'm not gonna lie that was so good thank you yeah the fire last day we're really help warm against feisty because she made sure that i had to like land it correctly because your space your micro spacing was like extremely affected against me so i needed to lock in for that oh thanks
help man and the throws are crazy too you're doing great well are we we're all doing great do we have like a break time or do we go straight into our next match because i don't know if all the matches are playing at the same time yeah other matches happening right now but they're not done yet i think oh thank god okay oh yeah i think i think they're also gonna show some of the other matches on stream like a replay of the other matches that they're playing upstream and then after it
who are we playing next again um let me check
we can leave this room right i think so all right i'll go play rank okay
all right guys it's rank time i can't lose a plat now that i'm at plat wait can we lose plat we actually i'm playing st colo's team next we're away okay who's the person i'm fighting um you're playing against st cola is bash world okay player are you gonna put me as the third seed again well because we're away like they're choosing oh oh oh thank god okay thank god um i again uh you're against you can lose plat okay we're never okay i'm playing quick We need to leave this lobby,
he says.
Oh, how did they know?
Wait, we gotta leave the lobby?
Yeah, they said team Brian has to stay in the lobby and team nephew leave and wait for our next match.
Oh, okay.
All right.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna practice on the right side.
Oh, yeah, I gotta have to go to the right side.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Oh, sure, you both of you.
Get me out of here.
Get me out.
I'm going to plug right now.
I'm joking.
I'm not going to plug.
I feel like they're not going to pick me.
For legal reason, that was a joke.
I mean, I don't know who they would pick, honestly, because I feel like they're all...
There's no way.
Yeah, they can't block the second one because that's the only move I know.
Still do they know.
Oh.
Ha ha ha.
Who's the two seed on my opponents?
Oh, you're you're playing Curious Joy, the my player.
Okay.
The my player.
Oh, she's really good.
Oh, no.
Please, please.
I think she's the seed of our our thing.
Oh, no, I messed up.
I mean, I think you guys are all.
I'm the same, to be honest.
Ah, shucks.
Thanks, coach.
Oh, my God.
He jumped out.
That was exactly what to say to motivate me.
Oh, how did he know?
Oh, I'm on the right side.
Oh, my God.
You are on the right side.
That's right.
Oh, God.
That's not right.
Guys, he adapted.
I wasn't, guys, I was not aware of him adapting.
Stupid fighting game players adapting to my every move
This is why I won and done people I don't give them a chance to adapt
Okay How they're cheating Yeah guys search up my name I don't want to lose my plan It's not De-Honda.
Adapting is the name.
You should adapt on the fly.
I'm afraid you did adapt on the fly.
But that doesn't count.
Alright.
Not De-Honda.
It doesn't count.
Because he was playing Luke.
Oh.
try my best to calm down try my best all
right wait i need rio practice get off of aki i need rio practice right now get off of aki i need rio i'm playing rio next yes
get off aki doesn't matter
matter come on guys where are my reuse at yeah you can't the entire that far away where is where are they no oh wait i thought you're right i have to play on the god damn it life's not fair why is life not fair you gotta do the grabs a little later after the fireballs do my grabs later yeah because you keep doing it while like they're still in blackstone no one plays real i don't care you don't play ryu no no oh i'm just i'm fighting a i'm fighting a rookie ryu you might as well be the same i just need to remember what ryu does i i'm gonna say that i'm gonna lose to the rookie i can feel it i i can feel it It's because I'm also on the Capcon,
a Capcon channel.
I didn't even see.
I thought you didn't have level three because I was looking at mine.
Oh, oh my god.
That's right.
Oh.
You never expect this, right?
Oh, this is not.
Whoa.
There we go.
Wait, wait!
Oh!
How did he know?
How- how did he know?
How- how did you know?
That's right!
Punish time!
All right, here you go.
Oh my gosh, whoops.
Oh.
Oh my god, that's not why I went.
That, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Stop her dukinging.
Ha ha ha!
Punish time!
That's right.
Get in the corner, nerd!
Yes, yes!
Watch my cutscene, too.
That's right.
You can watch my cutscene.
I took it is the only move.
Oh.
Jab all you want.
Yes, but slam!
Oh.
Not to punish.
How did he know?
Oh.
That's right.
That's right!
What move would I use next?
Get out.
Fight back, Alan.
Please fight back.
Oh my god, he's fighting back.
Guys, he's fighting back.
Yo, why did you inspire him?
Oh, you know what that means.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Guys, guys, guys.
He's fighting back.
Why did you inspire him to fight back?
That's right.
Get the finish.
I'm not letting you win this.
He adapted.
Get out of your adaptation circle.
Get out of here.
Whoa.
Oh.
Out there you are.
Adapt!
I don't like it.
Stop.
Stop!
Oh my god.
Not the Punish counter.
I hate this.
I hate that he's adapting.
I don't like this.
He fought back.
Why did you inspire him, dragons?
Oh my god.
how dare you inspire him get him out of here there you
go no oh what okay
oh that's right you
guys will tell us when you're in the lobby right Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, I have to.
I have to be like, push it because of you.
God damn it!
How dare you make me play like a goddamn...
Oh, I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Come on.
Now this is training.
That's right.
You're not supposed to be able to wake up command grab, right?
Oh, you want to do that again?
Come on, do that again.
Come on.
Oh, my God.
Jesus, okay.
You're stupid.
Yes, get out.
Get in the court.
I don't care.
Get in there.
Kick it!
Oh shit, if it works, it works.
It works though.
Here we go.
Oh, guess what's next?
seat time he got created
yeah that's sumo right there don't get out i win thank you i'm good watch my cut seat
that's right practice i mean i think we're gonna start soon anyways Oh.
Are we starting soon?
Probably like...
Well...
Yeah, probably like five or ten more minutes.
Okay, I can put one more match in.
Yeah, I think so.
I saw a master...
We're not fighting.
Did a master ruin my lobby?
I'm sorry.
I want to learn how to play.
I...
What?
I'm not gonna be learning.
How is that good practice, guys?
I feel like, if anything...
Wait, what?
Okay.
Ping!
I was like, why did my punish not work?
Oh, my God.
Guys, this is bad.
This is bad.
This is very bad.
There you go.
My turn!
All right guys, I may have set up the bot to do a corner loot.
And I think I lost at the bot 15 times in a row.
So, uh...
Thank you ahead of time for carrying the next series.
Well, she can't be as good as a bot.
Oh, that's right.
Yeah, I set up the corner throw.
Oh, guess what?
Guess what we're gonna do next?
In the corner!
That's it!
Yeah!
The trick about turkey's turn is it never ends.
Turn up, burn out.
Oh, my god.
What do you mean, Shirouki?
Oh, no.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
Wait, he's a dad.
now oh what it's right yeah you ain't goddamn adapting my book what oh what oh the drive impact how oh hey oh wait oh no he went in he learned his lesson
How did he go?
Goddamn stupid jab.
I hate people who adapt to me.
This is not fair.
I miss when...
Oh.
You know what this means!
time that's right that's sumo pow come on you'll be impatient soon come on come on you're gonna be an impatient right come on hey come on come on come on come on Oh, you know what that means.
I knew you were going to get impatient, bro.
Oh, what?
Oh, I should have blocked.
That should have been blocked.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
That one.
Okay, that should have been.
Oh.
Oh, you know what time it is.
You, you, oh.
That's it.
I've had it with you.
All right.
We gotta get ready now.
I could only they said like it'll be done in 10 minutes I think I fought for like five minutes so I'm gonna chillax now ggs everyone ggs I want to play against it let me please sorry I'm sorry don't worry we have like intermission in between each round I'm fighting we have like what uh five more games to go I'm pretty yeah we have five more games to go guys ggs guys I am not trying okay I'm not trying the Master Ryu guys okay I'll do one game one game with the Master Ryu but not right now during the next intermission we'll do one game with the Master Ryu not today though actually today but not now not now but what if oh guys in what in magic land oh yeah okay i'm gonna use the bathroom i gotta pee i have some i have anxiety pee right now i'll be right back guys
come back i'm on my back i'm back oh you know what i i got what i wanted my goal was to win one one game and i did i won my 20 point game and i had to play one extra compared to everyone
so so i did my job i beat my yeah yeah i i got my one win so if anything else happens today i just got i got my one win that's all that matters yeah it's a big win too it's just group staging but that's fine with me i'm just happy to get the one win chat yeah yeah i actually have to figure out how how i deal with that on the night not be meta in the high elo but god damn he is definitely a knowledge check it is it's surprising it's surprising how people in plat don't even know how to deal with it
i'm yeah i'm eating some chocolate right now i'm stressed out of course i'm stressed out guys i'm
Can you blame me, chat?
Can you really...
Can you really blame me?
I think Street Fighter.
I think if I...
The thing is, I know some people were like, Oh, you were, like, so chill during Tekken.
The thing about Tekken is that I know I'm bad at...
Because, like, the people in my group stage...
The people in my...
beginner stage during that time for um techin they were all like really really really good for beginners so like everyone no one really had x like like sk was in my tier back then like now now she's in the master tier like i'm still in the beginner tier i'm i think yeah like i'm So the beginner tier and SK was in my tier
And it was my first fighting game too, guys It was my first fighting game too And I think like, I think two I think like two to three of the players Yeah, two I think all the players in my tier went on to become like High Elo FGC players too So like in Tekken I knew in Tekken like like I was like the underdog like no one had any expectations on me um yeah I beat SK during the finals like no one expected I think the I remember people were doing the predictions and I would say like it was it was like payday it was like hitting the jackpot for those who predicted me like no no but like barely anyone expected me to win the game in the finals like
yeah the believers won big
um so so like in Tekken I've had none of the anxiety and nervousness because I lost every game too during like I think I lost I've only won one matchup um during the Tekken slam um during the group stages and I won one playoffs during the only won one of my play like playoffs don't one that matters the most though by the way because it was the finals but so um so like I went there being like whatever no one had everyone like um has like zero expectations to me so I wasn't nervous because I was like I'm just trying I'm just trying my best and then street fighter I had that same mindset until I accidentally sweeped everyone during the group stages I was not expecting that i was not expecting i was honestly just messing around as well on zanke and that you know and then i put a giant like whoops oopsie a giant target on my back yeah and then and then then i got like super scared and anxious after that like
insanely hard against me and i i yeah
oh yeah and everything and so like um and then and then you know and then after that i didn't touch street fighter um for an entire like a year plus after that um so i'm i am i feel like technically I am still a new player because I have I don't play fighting games and like I haven't touched any uh I haven't touched any like fighting games in general and I didn't uh so yeah like I did I will say my past experience did help because it eventually start slowly came back to me but I still it was still like yeah I just learned really really quick and I was learning an entirely new character too um so i did i felt like i did improve a lot within those three days yeah um if you what's drive reversal on block i think like uh what's the what's the frame data on that yeah my fast reaction time helps too you try your best and have an open mind for anxiety and then you're in the nose thank you thank you yeah so that's why like now i'm like super afraid because a lot like even though there's like
three other there's only like other players I'm playing against all three players like well I don't know about bash because like um I don't know about bash but I know the other two players were labbing against me um to make like you know trying to understand my mind which um which is very hard because even I don't understand my own mind uh so it also makes me very scared because in in Tekken nobody labbed me And then everyone's like,
it's fine.
Nobody, everyone's just like, it's fine.
No one really laughed me.
But in Street Fighter, I feel like so many people laughed because I play the most gimmicky characters, too.
I play the most, like, either the most silted characters or the most, like, gimmicky.
So that's why, like, yeah.
for it to download something that when there's nothing there yeah how do you download something when there's nothing uh yeah i'm the knowledge check hasn't i'm like where you have to adapt basically like i i basically test how well how well you adapt to me on the flat um yeah so oh Okay.
I want to see what the order is.
Oh, everyone.
No, we don't know the order yet.
Oh.
Yeah, staring into the void for too long.
And Doki stares back.
I got my invite.
I don't know if you guys did.
Yeah, I got it.
I'm in already.
Okay.
she's in oh yeah that's why I'm so nervous now that's why I'm like really really nervous because like you know the anxiety of like everyone having such like not okay not maybe not everyone you know because like I I will assume that the the opponent's chat is cheering them on but you know um oh you know how a lot of people have expectations on me so that makes me super more nervous but um not me i expect you to thank you guys i appreciate that we had to start taking training spots immediately or i'm sitting here i i appreciate that they said in every training spot to deny us the ability to practice wow i have i got i got that's smart yeah does anybody want to practice No.
Oh, I practice against you, Dan.
Oh, okay, okay.
Actually, I'm playing against mine.
The thing is, I don't know if that mine is going to be like my mine.
So by playing against me, I might be training you for bad things.
Yeah, probably.
So it's all good.
No, I'm just kidding.
No, it's all good.
No, it's...
Thank you guys.
I really appreciate all you guys believing in me.
Yeah.
And I expect you to make funny Honda headbutt moves.
And I haven't...
this fight so far
basically you're holding it back and forward thank you guys i really appreciate it i'm trying to shake off the anxiety emily you got to play first oh i'm first yeah it's it's you and then frodan and then me and then doki why am i last why do i have to wait could i just go now okay they don't want to put you on the on the match that's worth 20 points because they know that you would have this don't we don't do that who's the one that's worth me thanks then me twice you yeah yeah if i see he's got this i don't like that now you're good so we have to wait on there too yes we got this guys i believe oh yeah okay saving you're right so i don't got it i know y'all got it yeah yeah don't worry they saved the best for last you know how to end the show head but why does her thing not have a picture yeah i don't understand why no one has a picturing yeah there's a there's a setting no there's a setting so that like characters oh isn't oh there's no point yeah there's no point people can't use
skins because some people use the swimsuit edition stuff and it's kind of distracting do i feel like take that out No, no, no, no, no, you can keep it because I'm not playing you.
But yeah, it's like, you know, how can you play when you're looking at that ass?
I think you might have to like get out of the lobby to disable it.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know if you could do it on the lobby.
Yeah.
Okay, that I think that Zangief skin should not be allowed.
Oh, the robot one?
Yeah, it's like actually...
It's actually distracting.
Like the way that he really...
He became...
clinking bro like he's just here like it's so bad that's so distracting oh wait maybe we shouldn't be saying that what if they what if they're taking the tech now they're all gonna turn into clinkers oh wait is there more than one character that has that skin no i think it's no it's just zing yeah it's just my cousin keep yeah but you should turn that off then because yeah yeah let me If I leave,
can I rejoin?
Yeah.
Let me see.
Options.
It's on matchmaking.
Oh, it's on matchmaking?
Yeah, like when you press square to go into matchmaking, you go like to the character select.
You know, to pick your character, you just pick the character.
But I think you press like...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Character.
Oh.
The best for that.
I'm remembering, guys.
We're now on the broadcast, so I'm remembering.
No, wait.
Wait, how do I do it?
You're like, you know what?
You take your character on the...
Yeah.
I'm so locked.
I don't know what you're on.
I'm on the PS4.
Oh, I'm on the press triangle.
Oh, opponent.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, got it.
Got it.
I'm very chill right now.
I wish Coach has played.
I'm so chill.
Me too, man.
We should have show match at the end.
Yeah.
I agree.
If you want to log on my account, nephew, I mean.
Would be funny if Capcom put that, put your shame at that exact moment.
I mean, I think it's fair to say our gameplay is pretty close.
I agree.
Yeah, me too.
Honestly, I think your whip punishes are better than nephews.
Your ken's probably also better than his.
Uh, true.
are they just like introducing the teams right now i don't even know wait we're not even on broadcast who are we waiting on yet yeah i don't know i think we're probably we're probably waiting on the other team to start so we start at the same time yeah i see i was gonna say like we're not even live but they are gonna take our our replays that's true take our replays and show dude i accidentally cursed when i was oh my god i just can't stop it yeah it's like it's fighting games you can't stop stop the toxicity i'm saying as as soon as i did it i was like oh my god man wait i shouldn't have said that all right i was so confused over swearing dude no i thought he was like when he said that like let's try because i'd be cursing so much so much i as soon as he said that i'm like oh my god it wasn't me and then you said something i'm like wait maybe it wasn't no it was definitely me it was definitely me a little bit for sure it wasn't just you oh thank god okay we all go down together yes
when i saw your stats oh oh yeah let me let me leave yo mine has to be so close yeah it's so close it's so bad
it's like they can't they like look at our footage and Yeah.
Yeah.
What is she doing?
Like, oh, they said there's not one freeze.
It says you guys can hit it.
We are starting.
You got this, Emily.
Just throw some fans.
She don't know what to do.
Okay, okay.
Throw fans.
Oh my god, I don't know.
Nice.
Another Mecca Gif.
Let's jump when she gets close.
Okay, guys, don't tell my team, but like...
Oh, you have to...
That actually...
Don't tell my team, but I know I should be watching, but instead I'm watching Ryden's team to my head span butt bod right now.
I want...
I'm looking at Chad's reaction to that.
That's how much I believe.
That's how much I believe in my team.
Bro, okay.
Okay, Brian's expression.
Brian's expression to me just spamming headbutt over and over again.
He's just like...
What am I supposed to do?
I don't know if he's disappointed or...
I don't know.
Anywhere near her, but I feel like I need to.
I don't know if he's...
button drive us through and just go for a jump show everyone i just like again but again oh my god i'm so lucky yeah yep that's dokey's gameplay all right
Nice.
Oh, nice dodge.
Okay, I have my two eyes are looking at both.
Nice dodge from Emily.
Nice.
Oh, I have you coming?
Oops.
That's fine.
Brow was actually really, really?
Brow was like, yeah, Nuki's gonna play on.
I like how someone chat was like, Toki needed five hours of coaching.
Five hours well spent.
Okay, he's jumping, she doesn't need it, of course.
You have a time step?
It was like at one hour.
You can swap between the two.
That's how much I believe in my team, guys.
And it worked.
Just careful.
She might be out here.
Oh my god, they're like, Doki's not new.
I haven't touched a game in a year.
You can't say that.
Brian, you know my retention was really bad.
Like, you know.
You know, it took so long to understand my mind.
Let's go, Emmy.
You're cooking.
Yeah!
You're going crazy.
She's jumping a lot on Wake Up now, so you can just like meet her.
Or go for grab.
Like, just media grab or media auto-light.
They don't know.
I've been watching Brian's balling.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Emily's cooking.
I knew she was.
I know she doesn't need my active participation right now.
I'm...
That's how much I believe.
Oh my god, perfect KO.
Oh my god, wait.
I saw that, but I didn't register.
Oh no.
Wait, okay, I'm watching now.
I'm watching now.
This could be the last match.
I'm watching.
Oh my god, that one punch.
One punch.
Oh, no!
Oh, wait, wait.
No!
Okay, okay.
They both messed up.
That's good.
get away from get away from him get away from her
oh my god oh that was so good that was amazing i think i think no one can tell no one can tell i was half watching that don't ever agree i am very supportive that's how i knew i was like i knew she's got this that was so good you guessed right like every time i see i i i knew she's got this guys you got this i got away with it too all right bottom
bottom bottom bottom bottom yeah nobody snitch okay four four three more three more games until two more games until it's my turn two more games until it's my turn oh
am I feeling?
I think I'll just be nervous the entire time honestly um just because like I didn't realize there were prizes I went to like the orientation thing and then like we have to be in the orientation thing like an hour um an hour before and um i wasn't i didn't realize like wait first place goes to japan and a thousand dollar each person i i joined because i was like oh it's sponsored by capcom and i wasn't sure that like um it was supposed to go to like the capcon tournament or what uh whatever it's called i don't know exactly what it's called So,
like, that's why I wasn't expecting, I guess.
I didn't realize until, like, you know, when we, like, an hour before we streamed, I was like, oh, my God, wait, there's actual money involved.
I was like, oh, my God, I thought we just do it for fun.
I'm here for it for fun.
to join for fun i'm catching your buttons also like i didn't expect to get picked too that's the thing i was not expecting to get picked in general
because like i didn't know how many people signed up for it because like i said for those who didn't know like how the players were selected a bunch of people applied they send a capcon send me an email asking i would like to uh apply for the uh capcon uh not for the tournament And they're like,
okay, and the captains do, like, a draft system.
So they look through the list and be like, who do we want for on our team?
So I was like, oh, yeah, I'll just sign up.
I was like, I don't know if I'll get picked or anything.
Like, I literally, my application for it was like, I did not sell myself at all.
I was like, I don't know how to block, and I forgot how to play.
Oh, my God.
This is like the mix-up.
Oh, that was so close.
It's okay, you still use the hourly meter.
Yep, yep, yep.
What am I what?
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, that's crazy.
Oh, my God, she's adapting.
That's illegal.
I play the same way.
How dare you?
Oh, no.
I think you can jump out her more too.
I don't know how to use the blue button or the, what was it, the green dash.
I know I did it on Geek, but I legitimately forgot how I did that.
My hands cannot do that many buttons.
Yeah, that green dash, I don't know how to do that.
I forgot how.
no i know it's my l1 but like my butt my hand can't it's not cannot reach that right now it's my there's no reaction to it you're like oh jokia has good reaction time but like for the blue button and the green button the the green dash there is barely a reaction time for that yeah just headbutt headbutt and blood slam that's all i need
and they'll never know my first move i think i think they're going to know though later i don't know if i'm gonna beat the aki though um i think because like uh the aki player has had a lot of experience playing fgc okay but we'll do our best yeah don't mess with that winning formula if i get one round off of the aki that's all that mad that i'll be so happy
Jesus Oh no They don't want us to talk when they're playing Because they'll be too distracting for them Yeah I got mirror Yeah I think also you can drive rush or her more She's not really checking it Okay You're talking I can't give any tips All I can be like Good job guys I don't know what's going on They're like Oh you can drive rush Blah blah blah And I'm like What I'm just like,
I have no idea what they're talking about.
Like, they're just giving advice.
All I can do is like, good job, guys.
You're doing great.
That's my feedback.
God, this is like the poke game of the century.
Bro, there's so much blocking.
I hate this.
Too much blocking.
More attack, please.
Oh, no.
You might be wise, so...
Okay, yeah.
Oh, man.
My timings were just off.
Good try, good try.
Don't worry.
It's looking okay.
Yeah.
I should have...
I think it was...
I could have won by then.
It's okay.
We fight them again.
Yeah.
I still just win this.
Oh, my...
or make it close you know you don't have to just make it close if i don't got it don't he got it
all right no she's doing a good job like keeping me out because like i thought i could jump yeah we fight just rely on the 10-pointer and she was like checking my dry brush so it was like and then the fans are drafted pretty well yeah yeah that's all good no i'm not a 10-pointer now i'm a uh i mean i'm not a 20-pointer i'm a 10-pointer um it's it's only the third match the third match is the 10 pointer wait is it it's like first to 50 or no i don't at this point i don't even know anymore i don't understand the first to 50 thing because it's like we already got our 50.
i think that's for the matches like later oh seating i see i see so we just have to play everyone Okay, and then after this is like the real game.
We played them again, I think.
Yeah, afterwards, they see us in the playoff bracket and depending on where we are.
We play.
It's better to be higher suited though.
Wait, do we not play them again on the opposite side?
No, no, no.
What happens from here is we play every team one time, and then they rank the teams based off their performance in the group stage.
And then if you're the best performing team, you go straight to the finals.
If you're the second best performing team, you wait in the semi-finals.
we go if we if we're the number one performing team then we're just waiting in the finals okay I was thinking if um because we played them on home team right we played as them as home team I didn't know if we played them as a way also no no we don't have that's it yeah I think the first he'd also one gets home advantage in the finals so like you really want to be first okay hi yeah we get to chill it's okay if we're not yeah we could yeah we'll climb our way up We get extra warm-up Yeah,
and if not nephew will warm up the opponents for us as well No, no, no last team they basically have to do like they have to fight everyone Basically if they make it I was gonna say like which one I forgot it's been so loud.
I just forgot who which one is like our player Oh my god But these guys are gamers
I swear, I don't see, like, any Honda's in my, you know.
I still think I fought, like, one Honda the entire time.
During my climb, and I won.
The Honda was actually trying, and I was like, hit, but...
Oh, no.
God, stupid blocks.
Whoa!
Only after this is my turn.
Jesus, the corner.
I assume like Kimberly doesn't do much damage, but she's really really fast.
Does it hit?
Oh, yeah!
Now I just try and DI her here.
I'm gonna go for a driver's jab just in case.
Oh.
Oh god.
Oh my god, it's so...
Oh my god, he's so...
He's so scared.
That was so risky.
You are nasty.
I like it.
Thank you.
Oh my god, he was so scared of you.
I'm scared of myself.
Oh yeah, once you're just like me.
Once I get you in the corner, it's too late.
Oh, oh, oh no.
Oh, yeah, he does a lot of damage.
Look at that damage.
Oh, my God.
Stop adapting.
Play the same way.
Oh,
is that not how Kimberly's supposed to look like?
I was like, that's the way I legitimately thought that was how...
All the Kimberly's I thought looked like this.
i thought one other kimberly and she looked like this if you see her walking forward you can like jump in with a button but if you see her just like charging back for the cycle question i just legitimately at that point i thought this was part of the game like part of her default okay oh my god it is it's not over yet
jesus you know so much i hate it i hate them I hate that he's adapting.
Oh!
Press the wrong button.
Okay, I thought that was so cool though.
But I guess not.
I think I was left.
Yeah.
I thought she like dodged it and everything.
I was like, that's so cool.
Jesus.
The chip damage.
That really sucks when you're burned out.
Oh my god, one...
the one HP and dream right here.
Oh,
that's so scary.
Wow.
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
Whoa.
That was so close.
That's the thing.
I don't know which team is the strongest.
Yeah, because there's a lot of players.
I haven't researched any of the other players.
Oh, nice reaction.
Yeah, this is a 20.1.
So this is like...
They believe in this guy the most.
Whoa, perfect!
That's crazy.
The throw loop.
They don't expect the fifth one.
That's the thing.
Like, you're like, there's no way she'll do it again.
See, this is why I always headbutt.
Because they're like, there's no way she'll do it again.
Exactly why.
it oh no perfect no oh no this is really bad because he feels like he does so much oh is it oh it hits after you block scissor kick and burn out you can jab the zero at best okay because like the chip damage for it seems so scary in general oh
Oh, nice!
Yeah, you could probably do more neutral zones, too.
Because she gets baited to cycle pressure, though.
Okay, last match.
Crazy.
Everyone's adapting now.
Oh, hello.
Oh, so much blocking.
I'm not used to it.
It might, though.
Nobody blocks.
Am I, you know what?
Everyone just attacks.
Is this what Street Fighter is supposed to look like?
I'm like, oh my god, this is what Street Fighter is supposed to look like.
The one time that I don't drive is yet.
I'm not used to it.
This is like a different game I'm watching right now.
what I had to play from all the ring matches I played this is so different that dodge is so sick though like even though like she didn't hit it like she didn't she got hit at the end that dodge is crazy it was scary oh my god it's lagging you can wait for some drive gauge to come back or that works for you just started lagging a little bit it's okay
Yeah, it's hi, Master.
Yeah, but even then, like, I felt like everyone else was, like, blocking, and I was, like...
For me, I was just like, I'm just attacked.
Good job.
What does this spray paint mean, guys?
Oh, my God, it just... What?
What was that?
Oh, my God, what did he... It just lagged so bad.
It looked like she dropped a combo.
I don't even know that's fine.
Oh, it's Kimberly.
Kimberly's playing right now All right, sorry, that's her name feisty sorry feisty Her name is but that's Kimberly.
I forgot that's a kid.
Sorry feisty.
That's Bruh, that's Kimberly's name What should I do?
You could do the driver's job
she she is kimberly have you think about it jesus
oh no oh no not the throw loop no no no no no oh nice oh that was so close yeah just when you jump don't do the elbow drop just if you're five it's best of five what the heck i've never seen that move before yeah yeah there's one more round god being the 20 pointer sucks nice yeah first to three is it two two i thought it was two one i'm sorry they all blurred all these matches have blurred together
continuous match, you know, like, it feels like I've been watching one big game.
Yeah,
she can get that even in Lurna.
Oh my god, that's smart as hell, and I wonder if this guy was their 20 pointer.
Because they pick who gets to be the 20 pointer.
Yeah, they're smart.
You can try and do more run stops.
Because if she does DI, you could DI back if you run stop.
Okay.
Wait, is that bison?
I just realized, bro.
I was like, oh my God, wait, this is bison.
I thought it was a different character.
I didn't even realize.
I was like, man, I've never seen this character before.
I just realized it was bison.
The costume looks so different.
Yeah, I literally just realized it.
Yeah, that skin is crazy.
Oh, okay, I see it now.
I see his, like, little foot thing.
Oh, my God.
Damn.
What a combo.
Oh, my God.
He's still...
He's still alive.
Oh, that's scary.
Oh, they're so scared.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
That's scary.
Try and bait a dry reversal
Oh my gosh Nice What a combo Oh
This is intense as hell Oh my god Too slow No don't be too slow Kimberly Look at you Look at you No don't get throw loop Don't let me have throw loop Nice
Oh That charge is freaky oh my god get off get off of her oh my gosh oh they're all so scared now everyone is like everyone's doing chip damage too oh that chip damage oh no oh Oh no.
No.
Let's go.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
I'm shaking.
Oh my god.
That was insane.
That was actually clutch.
my god oh wow i'm sweaty man i don't know how to i don't know how to follow that up honestly not enough deodorant for my armpits but i know oh my goodness gracious oh thank god i have to play after that game you got it oh man i was sweating watching that one yeah my hands the riskiest thing I could have possibly done.
The TP, was it the TP?
No, it was the, like, I did the overhead.
I did, like, a combo on block into Drybrush overhead, a reset on my overhead at the end.
I wasn't playing it.
I have a heart rate monitor when I play fighting games, and I got to, like, almost 1.40 watching.
Dude, if I had a heart rate monitor, it would be on, I don't even know.
Yeah, watching it gave me, like, anxiety.
God.
All right.
I don't know.
He's a rookie.
I don't.
Guys, no, no, no, anything can happen.
You got this.
And butt his ass.
You're right.
Oh, okay.
Okay, what?
Okay.
I was gonna say what happened to him.
You can just keep...
You can't block this again!
This is why I go burn out.
I learned that they can't...
They don't know how to block that for some reason.
Oh.
If you block that, just do your heavy auto combo.
Okay.
They don't block this.
Let's go, Doki.
That's why I go to...
Wait, he left.
Why did he leave?
He did...
He wouldn't have done to me.
That's my thing!
Damn.
Oh my god.
You're cooking.
I'm not to watch this intro again?
You can skip it.
No, I'm making him watch it.
I ain't skipping.
That's me.
Oh, oh my gosh.
That's right.
What would I do next?
What would I do next, bro?
That's right.
What would I do?
There you go.
Nice.
Yay!
What would I do next?
Oh.
That's fine.
Oh, what?
It's okay.
That means I can do my thing again.
Alright.
Oh.
My grab didn't wait.
Sad.
Yay!
Okay, that was fast.
Let's go!
Oh my god, you're so good.
Yay!
Nice job.
I ain't here to block.
Let's go.
Nah, man.
We didn't pay 60 bucks to block.
Yeah, exactly.
I ain't here to block.
It felt like I was watching twice these match for like 20 minutes and then mine was just gone in five seconds.
Oh my god, I felt like I was playing it for 20 minutes, huh?
The contrast to the intensity of the last set.
Yeah, they see before Doki every time.
Ten of us four times refuses to elaborate and leaves.
Oh, that was good.
Y'all team, we're going crazy.
Another round in.
One more team.
Oh my god.
I just need to do it too.
You gotta be on top, right?
You gotta be the most points.
Unless you just have to do well in the last match.
The other team, I think, might be the hardest, right?
Yeah, unless I don't got 50 this time, because they got 40 the last match.
Oh, so they got the same.
Yeah.
So the next- Wait, so are we home or are we away next match?
We're home.
Nothing.
okay so it's good for us oh no i don't want to be i don't want to be there i feel like doki's like significantly more practice than the other four seeds oh okay but the the aki their aki has been playing a lot longer than me yeah i agree that he has been playing for a long time not they're not new oh yeah they're like flat two so i mean i'm okay with going but don't don't count on me too much you know yeah he had a year on her main i had three days on honda don't put me on the third seat
bro nobody want to do the 20 points because it's just a lot of responsibility exactly exactly i agree you're on the team down you guys are doing so good so bro i was sweating i'm like oh my god i'm gonna let my team down it's gonna be over No, no, don't worry.
I'll let our team down first, so you don't...
I'll throw the next game, so...
You can't look at it like that.
Oh, my God.
So, IDOM is...
That's CarQ, right?
The Honda player?
Yeah.
Oh, they're labbing right now, guys.
They're literally labbing against me right now.
This Japanese party...
Their coach is labbing against me!
What the heck?
Help your other players.
So we're tied with them.
So it's basically whoever wins.
They're actually laving against me right now.
Where are we sitting with the coaches?
I'm literally watching the coach laving.
I trust spicy.
Don't trust me too much, man.
I'm saying.
It's another bison, right?
Yeah, it's another bison.
I trust the anti-tech.
You look good against bison.
Did I?
Because that was last hit.
Last game, last round, last round.
skate all right
oh i guess we can like do the rank right now right it'll be a do you know when our next match is gonna be yeah uh they're on the b-right back screen for three minutes right now and they're probably gonna yapp a little bit after that so we probably got some time all right sweet okay it's my turn to lab against the aki all right all right guys aki's only all right uh can you guys hear me i think like monitor pros one second one second guys akis only now i only won akis
all right what
about that master ryu fight okay and one master ryu
you like all
right oh my god chill i've been fighting against like oh my god chill i forgot to fight against like a real player yeah okay street fighter just crashed my pc froze so that game was so fast i forgot how to play i legitimately
me a sec i actually forgot how to play the game because that game was way too fast
okay that's fine i got so much out of it no perfect that's right did we did we figure out the results i'm trying to pull up the stream but i don't see if anything happened well i am seeing 150 oh all right oh okay so they're ahead of us no they're tied because they won their first match like they did exactly the same as us okay so basically the winner of this series yeah wait so we're tied for points yeah we're tied okay yeah we're in doubt at a grab yeah you
didn't expect that did you and fight that oh you didn't expect that right I know.
The butt slam out of nowhere.
Oh my gosh.
True you.
That's right.
Oh my god.
Nobody ever expects this moon.
For some reason.
Get out of here.
I'll give you a freebie round.
Um.
That's right, I'm fighting the Master Ryu.
All right, where's the Master Ryu?
Where's the one Master Ryu?
All right, why don't you guys get out?
I need to fight the Master Ryu.
Adam, get out.
You lost.
We're trapped.
I need to do one game with that Ryu.
Oh, wait, here we go.
Okay, never mind.
We'll do this side.
All right, Master Ryu, get in here.
Let's see how...
Let's see if I survive longer than like 10 seconds.
Let's see if I can get a hit in.
My goal is to get one hit in.
Jesus, 35,000.
Oh.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my.
Oh, God, you got hit by a plop player.
You got hit by a plop player.
That's so embarrassing.
Oh, that's so embarrassing, bro.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that...
Bro!
I told you.
You can't figure out my mind.
Oh, you're going to grab me?
I'll grab you back.
Oh, my God.
Oh, you should expect that, bro.
You can't.
I told you, you don't.
Bro, people don't know how to predict my mind.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
I got...
You know what?
I am proud of myself, guys.
Like, I am so proud of myself.
crowd.
Oh, guess who takes a round off you?
Oh, my God.
It's about sending a message, guys.
I got a round off a master player.
Let's go.
No shot.
I got a round.
That's right.
I told you.
You don't know what I'm thinking.
Oh, my God.
He's throwing it down.
You didn't surrender!
That's right!
You didn't expect that, right?
You didn't expect me to block!
You didn't expect me to jump over that too!
Nobody ever expects it!
Oh shit, okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, oh no.
Oh, no, this is bad.
Oh!
I don't think Ruda's for you, bro.
Guys, I don't think Ruda's for him.
Bro, what happened?
Matt, wait.
Master.
Bro, let your...
Let your big bro back on his account.
Back on his account.
uh
what oh
All right.
Insane.
Here comes a new challenger.
The VM is on there.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
That's right.
I'm just saying Oh, you should let his big bro back on the account
Oh, whoa, whoa, whatever does it mean Oh, it hit me That's right Oh, they never expect this Oh, they expected it
That's right I don't need my drive burn out forever wait why do you want me to go first you don't want to it's too late now
oh my god oh my god am I just grabbing too early like what's happening that's fine I have level three watch my cutscene I'm still getting hit by the van watch it
That's right, it doesn't matter if I lose.
I made him watch my cutscene.
Are you trying to grab in the middle or after?
Oh no.
Oh no, you're grabbing too late.
Oh no, it's fine.
It's fine.
I got him to watch it.
I can't touch it.
He's too tall.
Oh.
What?
You have to dash and then walk.
I don't even know what I did there.
Oh shit.
Like you're getting- Oh my god, what?
What is this combo?
What am I watching?
Oh.
You guys hear me?
Yeah.
This one's being super weird.
My turn.
Oh, not my turn anymore.
My turn now!
training slot.
I'm going to take those other training slots so they can't get this.
Nice.
Do you have a standings link, nephew?
I'm not sure, but oh my god.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Guys, I lost her purpose because I'm supposed to be in the lobby now, guys.
Oh god.
Guys, I gotta be in the lobby.
Give me, I gotta leave.
I had to, I threw that so I can go to the lobby now.
Guys, that's why I threw.
That's why.
Mm-hmm.
See, everyone's here.
Guys, everyone's here.
I had to leave.
Oh,
man.
Oh, man.
Wait, I'm first?
Wait.
I thought I'm...
Wait, I'm first?
What is this information?
I put you last.
am i'm last i'm last okay that's you and i can't i never be in the middle wait what'd you say okay all right the jp thing not that one i don't want to be first or last i want to be spam a bunch of things and then i need to get out second oh my no i want to be in the middle i don't want to be first or last i want to be in the middle yeah you can do that or like on dry brush right yeah i want to be second drive rush you get first the worst second the best guys oh already no i'm not no third is the 20 point game chat third is the 20 point game first is the first is the uh the test first second and fourth get closer before your dry brush like it's not gonna read from both screen oh okay but this one i'm like more chill about because like i know um no i took a round off of a master reu that's different i hate to be the third i was the third before i had to be the third um i'm scared like she had to like i don't know how long she's been playing because like The thing is,
her Aki was, because like, she and I started in the same tier, but she kept with Aki.
I, she kept playing Aki.
I didn't kept playing Keef.
No, you can jump first and then start dry fishing.
No, I have to play.
Everyone has to play.
Oh, I got, oh yeah, I got around against, you're right, I got around against the Master Aki.
You're right.
I'm just going to jump twice.
So this is going to try to, I'm more chill about an even match than, i am with a with the match where i'm like oh they're at the same level as i mean we're i'm more chill with someone that like we're similar to rank versus like someone that's way below me because if i you know if i messed up it's much more stressful
okay never mind sorry false alarm this one is less stressful he was sitting down yeah that was the aky that forced me to play super passively i couldn't go like straight on the bunga
I had to like be like very oh wait I didn't want to be here give me out of here I was trying to inspect it carry up everyone gets points until and then we play bracket I wish I stayed longer and then we played bracket and then it's like yeah I rented a girlfriend I um visited yeah i got two points i got like i won two games that's where we're going up already the pokemon center what else oh that plays already yeah i bought some pokemon cards oh you didn't buy any ripdown cards already yeah i don't know were they released in japan did you open any wait so what was it like oh that was kind of awkward i think i'm bad at talking to women what was your goal like were you trying to vis her up no i wanted to well i wanted to try rising her up a little bit but i also wanted to know what she actually did and she basically just goes on dates with really she said they're really respectful men and she earns a lot of money wait wait so she's she's she's an actual rent a girlfriend yeah yeah it's
like her full-time job money i pay too much you have to pay extra for holding hands and i only held her hand 20.
no way wait wait is it like hourly or like yeah it's hourly wait you gotta pay extra for holding hands yeah yeah and it's hours how much was it per hour um okay it was i think it was like 50 60.
okay okay so it was 50 i think actually i don't know the conversion exactly 40 50 but because i was streaming she doubled the price And then, oh.
And then I paid an extra.
Mm hmm.
And then you get surcharge for drinking and you get surcharge for holding hand.
Damn.
Sounds like you got.
Wait, so what does the what does the vanilla option give you?
She worked you.
You know what?
I respect the hustle.
Like, what do you get from just like the default price?
You get nothing pretty much.
Well, you get to hang out with her, but you can't you can talk to her.
so just a conversation talking at least yeah the talking is free i see okay talking how many stars did you give her afterwards oh there was i don't think there was a place to rate her really and how they get recommended um on the website like they just have a bunch of girls listed they have like 50 girls listed and with like just huge descriptions about them and what they like to do and then you pick one oh so what did you where was the description that made you pick the one you did She speaks English.
Did she speak good English or was it like broken English?
Oh, it was pretty good.
It was good English.
Oh, geez.
That's crazy.
How much was the total in general?
I think it was like $3,400.
How much?
Okay, okay, never again, guys.
The thing is, I don't know if the price all is double for streaming.
How long was the date?
That amount of money in my life.
Uh, like four hours?
Emily, if you pay me that much, I'll do way more.
I'm just saying.
Oh, okay.
I'm done.
She'll fly right over to you.
There's no extra charges, too.
No extra charges.
Everything's included.
One-time payment.
That's crazy, man.
That's crazy.
No, she said 3,400 guys.
not 300 to 400 yeah it's 3.4 k guys no no no three to 400 oh three to four okay i thought i said you said 3400 no no no no i would not say that much oh my god okay yeah she's not flying over like but i paid for it i never had a hand holding and for the the alcohol drinking when you when you held her hand did you feel something was it really awkward i don't think i'm gonna hold another girl tight ever again
you make it sound like it wasn't enjoyable well the talking was fun it like it got pretty like better you know obviously it would but like as the time went on when we got to know each other better but yeah i mean just because did you go straight for it did you like can like you met her you introduced names and you started holding her hand and of course that's no no no we talked for like 30 minutes and then she told me there she has like a list of extras so i has to look at them okay oh my god she handed you the menu no yeah she handed me the menu the menu i forgot was that the most expensive thing holding her hand i don't think hand holding is the most
I actually don't know what the most expensive thing was.
And a couple was making out in the bathroom during the stream.
Oh, oh, yeah.
And so we went to karaoke, right?
And so after I went to karaoke, wait, did you have to pay her extra for her to sing that karaoke?
No, no, no, no, no.
I didn't.
I went to the bathroom.
I'm so bored of this story.
All right.
Okay, I'm ready.
Yep.
All right.
Lock in, Emily.
Okay.
I'm locked in, but like this didn't go so well at TwitchCon.
You got it.
It's okay.
It's not Twitch cut.
Okay, okay.
You have your setup.
Yeah, guys, I think we know what the most expensive option was.
Wait, what?
Okay, I was gonna say it.
Wait, how is this the same tier?
Like,
how is it gonna be a little confused?
Oh my god, this is intense.
I think JP is definitely...
I was told that JP is annoying in any Elo.
Especially the high Elo.
Good JP is really annoying.
Wait, actually I remember.
Brawlpo fought against her.
It was so tilting for him to fight against her.
I remember now.
It's okay right?
close.
I told you guys how yellow tree fighter is like so different to watch compared to like what I had to blit.
Now observe.
Oh my god you have to like time the blocks too when they do the traps.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh that was good.
A master load should stop existing.
Just an uninstall They just have one day where they just ban all JP players Like this is the day where JP players aren't allowed to play They should do that, you know Like days where like certain characters aren't usable Like they lock it Imagine Imagine they lock like Oh,
that's fine They lock certain characters for a day It's like Street Fighter is safe I swear I i swear it would it would improve the game guys it would honestly like make the player base will go up that's fine you can look for more button drivers it's like on friday we ban jp for a day yeah every day where everyone can be happy
go go now observe go go
here now observe here yes no now observe here that's so annoying i'm lagging
yeah i don't i could tell how annoying he is just from the voice acting too that means it's like good voice acting but it's still pretty annoying either like do your auto light yeah it's like a tick tock mpc banana she's jumping forward
Oh my god, you're right, JP is like the Timo, a street fighter.
I think he doesn't sound like, he doesn't sound like such, so snobby, I think it'd be fine.
Because when I do the headbutt, it doesn't sound annoying.
It's silly.
It's like, everyone cheers.
Everyone cheers.
He's like, you go, Honda!
You go!
No, don't hate him.
No, you don't understand, Pop!
with Smurf.
Apparently, 2XKO Timo is so annoying.
I read that, like, Seijam has to start the tournament one hour early because of the Timos.
Because it takes a lot of time.
Like, I don't know why, but...
They have to start, like, an hour early.
Yeah, she's also jumping when you drive us to, so I'll just look for an entire Zay, too.
That's just Timo.
Or Timo.
Not Timo.
You won't expect it a fourth time and maybe a fifth time?
Oh, they expected it.
I was going to say, there's no way she'll expect it a fifth time, guys.
But she did.
God, that is so oppressive.
That is actually so oppressive.
She's very...
What?
what this is this is so tilting the watch i understand now
now have you done trying to do the now observe yes now now observe someone take this old man to the retirement home see i told you guys we should We should make it so that no JP for a day.
And then Street Fighter would be like, wow, it's like everyone's so much happier for some reason.
Nice.
Damn.
That's okay.
No.
God, damn.
Here.
Now observe.
Oh my god, you have to blow.
lock all that too.
I think that's the worst part.
Burn, baby, Oh my god, what a counter.
Yeah!
Anytime you get closer, just watch out for the heavy punch.
Please stop praying for my grandfather.
Oh, how did she expect that?
Go!
Oh my I got the jabs.
In fact, I have three more games after this too.
I'm so like, oh god.
Not ready for it.
I was like, what's the gas for?
Am I behind?
Oh no.
No, I'm not because like we were like nice when she won.
Oh my god, I can't do it.
No.
Now observe.
I can predict her next move.
No.
Now observe.
It's like I know what her next move is gonna be.
Oh.
Stop.
Oh, he can't do it.
He can't do observe.
He doesn't have his magic.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Oh.
I'm glad I didn't try and play JP.
My brain does not have enough space for this.
Now observe.
Oh, how do you block that?
Was it timing?
Is she just got timed?
Yeah.
Okay.
Bro, how do you get close?
How?
How do you...
How do you get there?
Bro, it's like she owns 20 meters square of the territory.
Oh, she has to jump?
Like, how?
Bro!
Now observe.
Oh, my God.
Oh, does she still have the magic?
Bro, you can just spam this!
Be patient.
Bro, I...
I can't play against this thing.
It's like a rhythm game.
Yeah, that was close.
Yeah, you had one, the one game series you won, you played it really well.
Yeah, you did, and it was really good.
You should retire this character.
I don't think it adds any value to Street Fighter.
I don't think it would have.
That character should be retired, taken to a home.
And so they've already ungodless.
I'm going to reread the, so how how is jp not the evo champ yeah it's mostly he's gonna ex headbutt on wake up so you can either grab him or shimmy and jab him jab him grab him grab him grab him like i'll grab put the sleep guys i think he's getting old or he must eventually die of old age right
okay like how is he not like how is like uh fighter in the street evo and capcon cup um how is he not like forever the champion uh uh he joined i i actually i joined solo training by accident and then he did he won last capcon cup why didn't he get nerfed again don't they nerf characters that win the Capcom Cup?
I don't understand.
They should nerf every character that wins the Capcom Cup.
Alright, here we go.
No, they nerfed it.
How did Geep get nerfed, but this old man is still alive in my game?
Honestly, just give him one move oh that's me wait i'm gonna
i'm i see no one knows what to do no one does no i use half those moves except for the dash bro he's see he's using the head foot it's me nice nice oh oh yeah i think maybe more fireballs i have to start so you can't i know how they feel
help i don't know how what do you mean i don't know what to do what do you mean help him i'm not i'm if any thing i will not be helpful at all wait that's not fair this team has a honda player like they could just they could actually get additional coaching nice all right i don't have an aki player that give me additional coaching with fireball at the beginning yeah you could try like no they have a Honda player to coach it.
That's me.
They'll never expect.
Oh.
Okay.
I mean, they're doing the dashes.
I'm like, I don't know how to do the dashes correctly.
So I do the super headbutt, guys.
Oh, wait, burnout's good.
Burnout is so good for him.
that's fine oh unlucky no abuse that burnout that's what i always do oh it's the butt slam what the heck was that move oh that's bad oh i think on defense you can try like dp or something no it's not you mean dp it is good for me no no like um yeah just like our wake up like exdp or oh exdp and then you said super on wake up yeah level one is good because it's side switches too okay it's just funny watching another honda play because i'm like i think i'm just getting hit by like a lot of them but so like yeah yeah i mean he's really patient so yeah i'll just throw a fire because i don't want to get jump in on so i think i can maintain a little bit more space then if anything i think we'll be like We'll be in the semis,
if anything.
I don't think we're...
I don't know.
I think we have to adapt for the finals, but...
That's not fair.
The Hanna has, like, six moves.
Yeah, I know, right?
I just thought it was funny watching it.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, I forgot that they started.
I forgot I got kicked out.
All right, we're gonna watch Dragon Ball Z.
Watch this.
You gotta do this.
Come on.
I'm number one.
game
okay we're here now we're here we're speed no next game is the 20 point game
nice enough i think so okay we're back now yeah keep it up I hope Proudhon wins this because if we win the 20 point game I mean I actually called it out if we win the 20 point game then I don't have to win the Aki matchup I'm just scared about that I don't want them to relax that's why I don't want to be last I already be first
oh my god No, I was like, what?
We're headbutt.
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, nice.
That's a good count.
Oh, bro.
He does the butt slam so...
Yeah, the Genroids are doing good, though.
So you can keep doing them until he stops at once.
What does that move?
Never seen that move before.
Jeez.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Let me try this one.
Oh, man.
Let's try.
Oh, Honda.
Okay.
Nice try.
You just use the headbutt too much.
Wait, the headbutts are really effective even.
They are.
I told you.
Why else do I spam it?
It's about the like the rhythm as well.
Oh, don't say that.
Because Feisty clutches these.
Guys, don't say that.
Yeah.
I will try.
I don't even know.
Can we start yet?
Oh, no.
I wish I was first.
In the off-stream match.
That's why we're first and second.
I told you we're on-stream.
No, we're off-stream.
No, no, no.
Our first game was on-stream.
Okay.
Oh.
It's, yeah.
All right.
We do not see the pressure.
We do not see it, guys.
Yes, it's okay.
Oh.
There we go.
Oh my gosh, another Akuma too.
What the heck, Grandmaster?
How did Dom get this team?
Bro, it was drafted.
Was he, was he like first?
strap and he picked like oh sorry bison sorry i meant bison uh they both are like old and dying
nice never mind never mind never mind feisty's better feisty's better
I didn't see the points.
I just saw high master versus grand master.
So I didn't wasn't pay attention to the point system Never mind, but I see it so much better
Jesus, oh Oh
my god what what is going on?
What am I looking at?
This land so hard
oh my god please fight back nice
but i'm like heart beating for her am i dead i don't think so like my heart's beating for her and i'm not playing oh she's dead
jumping at him more.
At least from far, I think.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that's good.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I forgot to watch like, uh, best of five.
People downloading the game we're talking about.
adapting and downloading the plays no we play the same until it works
okay oh oh i think the hard part is that because there's two bison players watch out for the driver reversal on his wake up oh there's two bison players but i think both of them play differently too so she has to adapt to two different play styles for bison i assume right yeah and keep keep probably kicking him because i think he's catching his like pecs yeah yeah or back dash i think trying to back dash
so what does the music do guys
oh my god nice looking good looking good oh got this i'm cooking i'm cooking i understand more damage oh speed buff like just beat or does she do more damage too oh my god my heavy kick didn't come out it's okay oh and deals more damage oh okay that's so broken if she when she gets her alt
that seems so broken
oh mexican yeah we can do it after the stream after the stream or not after the stream i just think to myself i mean after the games after the games just uh if chat can remind me Like, I just synonymize the cell.
It's like, don't worry, guys.
I can't.
But if you guys can remind me after the tournament.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
When does this combo end?
Oh, this is scary.
Technically, Bison has one hit.
Oh, nice.
didn't really know what i wanted to do i know level one wouldn't have killed yeah that was good i think oh wait chat will chat's got you i knew it
i think the hard part is like street fighters literally like you're playing chess it's like it's like hardcore chess extreme chess
Jesus, this is so fast paced, dude.
Oh, no.
Oh, nice.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
Oh, what?
That hit?
She was so far.
Yeah.
I expect that to hit.
She was so far from the corner.
That was an accident.
I don't know what I'm doing.
That was a good frame tag.
You can try to show me over something here.
Okay.
Oh no.
At least the music's nice.
Oh, what a parry.
Her damage, I just realized her damage isn't, like, that high, though.
Oh, she waited for her.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
I controlled her.
Oh, was it 2-1?
And you controlled her so bad.
Yeah, her damage is really But she's so fast though
Yeah, because I was like bro she did so much like I saw so many moves But he's barely like she barely did any damage.
I was so confused
Oh I mean they're both burn up
Yeah, she needs to use like every move possible Oh my god Is this...
I knew he was gonna do it again.
Too thirsty for it?
Okay.
Oh, she blocked it.
Level 3, I don't care.
I'm cooking!
He's cooking!
Oh my god, he's just blocking.
What is this blocking game I'm watching?
There we go.
Nice.
No, but also, yay!
That is incredible.
Nice job.
Oh my god, but also don't, because I'm the last game.
You got it.
All right.
Oh god.
You got a dokey.
Let's go.
It's okay.
In the end, we fight them again anyway.
Doesn't matter where we're at, we still fight them again.
you know if i see if you're looking for a new controller i know someone who wants to rent a girlfriend and no you know what that would be great man yeah i got you
cool i'm so nervous i'm the tiebreaker no pressure yeah honey yeah
that we had the um me round rob and stuff so i know how she plays all right here we go you got this don't stress out you know everything is fine yeah everything do what you know what to do one move i know surely she won't know that move
surely she doesn't know it right yeah i don't think so she hasn't been watching right guys
She hasn't been watching.
Oh, wait, guys.
She has been watching.
That move you can do your heavy auto damage.
The one where she goes up.
Yeah.
They keep doing that.
Oh, okay.
You want to play patient.
Your Kaden's going to come back soon.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, I didn't expect that.
Oh!
That's fine.
Okay, there you go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, that heavy auto combo I think is really good.
Okay.
Oh, unlucky.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh no.
What's that?
That she makes you block.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, don't do EX HUD Buzzkill Fireballs.
Do your butt slams.
No, what's that?
Oh, butt slam.
Nice.
Oh,
no.
I think she was going to do that.
Oh, no.
Okay, you saw a little more.
Nice, nice, nice.
Looking good.
Keep it up.
Looking amazing.
Okay.
They locked in.
You got it.
Okay.
That's fine.
I don't like that she adapts to me.
That should be illegal.
Oh, my God.
I know she...
You can try Deioning her, too.
Oh.
Nephew!
Okay.
Nice.
That's not going to work out for you.
I did it when you told me that.
Nice.
Yeah, anytime you feel confident, you do the best land.
Wait, I get this!
Yeah, you got it.
I just made it in time.
You could try and go up for the grab, maybe.
The grab?
Okay.
Like the down special?
Oh, oh, I was gonna grab, but it didn't let me.
That's fine.
Also, she cannot.
Yeah, but slam for sure.
She can't anti-Ary.
Yeah, we did it!
We won!
We did it!
We're in the finals!
Let's get him!
No way, no way!
We're in the finals!
Wait, hold on.
We're automatic grand finals!
We don't need a year to practice Honda!
I just need a year.
I need three days and that's it.
Oh my God.
You're amazing.
You're literally crazy, dude.
Oh my God.
We're in the files.
I think we're in the files, right?
Yeah.
We're home.
We can just chill.
You know, we're home.
Yeah.
Let's go.
No way.
You have to carry.
Oh my God.
No, you carry, Doki.
No, you carry too.
bro that matchup you did two 20 pointer games oh my god i was stressed out during it too man we were all stressed up but we're in the grand finals baby we are dude no matter what we can get first or second yeah so like do we just wait how long do we how long do we wait for it i think we literally have to wait for both of their matches oh yeah it might take a couple yeah we got time oh i'm just gonna do a wrap for that oh well our match is the last match yeah so whenever we play that's it oh so they're gonna play 10 i think i'm gonna yeah i don't really understand how this works but it's gonna be at least what two matches yeah yeah i think it's at least like two hours before you play probably oh no wait two hours no i end stream here I'll be back here guys grabbing dinner I'll be right back JK guys I'm not ending stream it's probably like 1.5 hours but it could be like 2 hours if there are any delays that's true because we have to wait for every match yeah I need to play some game yeah
I probably should I gotta take a break though like from playing yeah if you're hungry you should probably eat now you know what I mean I'm hungry but I feel like I probably play better hungry oh yeah you makes you want it more you know yeah you're like i'll i'll only eat if i win wait that's crazy because if yeah okay oh my god oh i'm so happy guys i i'm gonna chill max i'm not gonna play for i'll play when the second gate like uh because there's two there's gonna be two matches uh full matches i'll start warming up during the second match i don't want get uh too exhausted you know uh from if i play if i play too much i i actually just brain off like i feel like that team is really strong so i i expect to meet them yeah no i think yeah i think they're definitely the strongest team and then the finals what is it first to 50 is that what they said i don't even understand it's the same thing i think it's the same matchup but it's just whoever gets the 50.
so we get to choose the seating okay okay i don't know want to be last why not i mean actually i don't think you should be third then no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no i think doki should be first or second because like we can get points easy that way yeah definitely win and then if i win we already have 30.
yeah exactly i'll take the first or second i mean we don't know who's gonna be in the final but most i'm pretty sure it's this team because they've like they had we they had the same stacks as us until they fought us yeah oh they just have like two of their tiers are just too good like fumi is definitely the best in her tier i think she's the only master in her tier everyone else is diamond and then sarotina is yeah i thought yeah yeah sarotina is the best in her bracket i think it's just i abused the head but like i just know you're better that's what it is you're better but she has the most experience too so it was like it was scary yeah she definitely has the most experience so it's two really good tears that they have so it's just tough oh my god yeah tough but not unbeatable i believe in us guys we're going to japan if not if not then we almost went to japan it's okay man i'm proud of us either way we were and everyone worked so hard yeah every point matter right like i said i
started playing on tuesday but yeah nah but you worked really hard though i feel like you definitely worked way harder than the other new people uh oh my god it's either we almost made it to japan or we're going to japan it's one or the other you picked a good character honestly oh yeah no i told nephew i was like i want the easy way easiest way to win i don't care damn nephew said hondo right away didn't even think about it yep yeah i mean he's the best choice man yeah you're right for sure
the one they're playing on stream right now it's already like the bracket right no oh no it's not it's not but they're gonna that means they're gonna play each other again
it doesn't who has to play each other is both of them right they're gonna play right after this again yeah they play each other right after again yeah yeah it's probably gonna be a while they're definitely going on a break oh my god at least two breaks i'm guys i'm just happy i'm happy we made it to the grand finals you know i had like very low expectations for myself so i'm just happy that um like i got there whatever win or lose i'm happy we got to at least second place
that's it yeah oh I'm happy I just have to play one the best part guys I just got to play one game after I don't even guys I will have you guys know I don't even know what happened that game I had against the Aki I don't know what I did I don't even know what I did in that game I already forgot like my minus blanked out in that entire tournament.
Like, I don't, I dipped to the Ryu and the jury, but I legitimately don't know how I won that game against the Aki.
I, I, you locked it.
I locked it so hard that I forgot what happened.
Yeah.
I told you guys, Bruno is good.
Did you not see what I did during Bruno?
I literally got so many.
any free hits from having being burnt out
look at all the heavy attacks that I got
oh yeah no one yeah no one expects the burnout you know like okay when people get burned out you would think that they would try and run away you know I didn't I didn't run away I went full in I knew the risk and I was willing to gamble it all away that's right I gambled the risk you get stronger with burnout exactly yeah burnout only motivates me proceeds to walk forward yeah
don't leak okay it's not because I've been literally doing that for my entire game.
That's been on the two.
I'm just happy, honestly.
I'm happy that...
I was so scared.
She was the...
Like, Seraphine was good.
So, like, because, like, she was the one that made me the most scared during Sage I'm Slam because I was so used to playing Pass.
Like, I was so used to playing super aggressive on Zanke if I remember and so like she made me so scared um playing against her during when we were both in beginner tier for the Zanke versus Aki and then from that's why like and then she kept playing you know what I did I uninstalled I she was much strong she kept playing and then she did the next stage I'm slam too I think right she did the because like she was in the second sea jam slam as well right after um yeah
and i came back i came back here oh yeah we'll do the birthday song now we have we can do it now oh but thank you everybody for all the memberships and um for all the members the super chats and everything and the follows i really appreciate it guys i'm literally slouched on my chair right now uh-uh that's how our last night am um yeah i played everyone was playing street fighter i played marvel i told you the marvel rivals helped me figure out the cooldowns guys it the the marvel rivals helped guys um l thank you for the super chat thank you thank you adoki it's me oh yeah um anyway next thing i'll hear your birthday song happy birthday to you birthday to you happy birthday dear mexican happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday yeah they're cool down chain um because i've only played it i don't get two sessions like off stream where i played rink um i think like i don't know i retained the information a lot better on honda um for uh i think it's just like and even though it was like a
year ago i definitely did.
Uh, I thought I wouldn't remember what was going on, but I remembered.
It took me a while to remember.
It really did.
Uh, but like, I'm glad.
I'm glad I did as well as I did.
Um, uh yeah i sort i i guess i sort of remember recovered the muscle memory but like it's so different like zangif and honda are two very different characters zangif like the play style is so different i don't think it's same i feel like i was learning the only thing like i retain is just like where to press my butt like the auto so the muscle memory was the auto attack and um that's it
that's it everything else was like different for me so I don't like you were like oh it's just because you played Zane Geef so the knowledge transferred over but legitimately all the moves I did on Zane Geef is so different from what I had to do on Honda so it was like learning the new characters to help again but I also had two amazing coaches I had Nephew and Big Bird helping me out though like back to back so that like that helped out a lot as well um oh that actually helped out a lot uh well thank you super chat thank you thank you my birthday is today too glad you locked in a one you're at least one game for the training yeah i did it now i can oh my gosh now i can chill until one hour before uh one hour before the or uh i'll go in one hour for the match to warm up.
So we'll watch this.
We'll chill with this game.
I can't put the stream up, but we can watch the matches too if we want when it starts.
But Will, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Will.
Yeah, happy birthday.
The mainstream loves me.
I'm not even playing.
Did they show my...
No, they didn't show our games, though.
I don't understand how...
Our games weren't shown.
We only had, like, one game that was shown.
Um...
Yeah, they only...
Oh, are they gonna watch it now?
Oh, okay.
I mean, we could watch ourselves.
Oh, I'm literally slouching right now.
I'm so chill.
They're seeing the replays.
Nice.
I'm sorry if I swore I was like in the zone for it if I did swear I'm so sorry I don't know what I wasn't thinking, okay, if I did swear.
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, they're watching replays, but, like, we don't have to watch, I mean, I'll watch the replays, but, you know what I mean, I know what happened.
been uh no it's not my match yet it's uh it's uh who's my it's emily's match they're not watching us yet we already know we experienced it yeah yeah watch me you won't watch me do the head okay but she thought i was gonna do the headbutt all the time but i mixed it up you see that I mixed it up.
Now I put in the heavy attack.
I saw she was blocking my headbutt.
She didn't know I had a third move.
She didn't know my move number three.
She's like, oh, she's just going to spam headbutt because the other two players, the other two players, I just used a headbutt.
But she didn't know about my third move.
The third secret move.
It's just that simple.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, and I blocked, too.
She didn't think I would block.
This was the one moment I blocked.
Wait, okay, don't get...
Okay, I don't remember.
Okay, my fourth move is...
Okay, my first move...
Okay, I shouldn't say it on stream.
Whatever you're...
Okay, now whatever you're looking at my vibe.
I won't let you tell you my fourth move.
is a secret I'll never tell
don't yeah don't reveal the fourth move guys no no one knows no one knows my fourth move
oh but
um bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
yeah not even i know what it is
it's a secret guys i told you it's a secret if i don't know the fourth move they don't know the fourth move either yeah if the fourth move is whatever i feel like it
exactly it's how i keep them on their toes the mind game oh my god it's been three hours though oh my god also why okay this is also why i haven't joined any stage mslam after the street fighter one because it was long i i got too tired
it made me too tired um and this is shorter this is less teams yeah yeah yeah it was yeah honestly the three hours did pass by really fast though it did pass by really fast but like the thing about the slam like um was that like it's three it's three different days of that amount of hours plus the labbing too so like it made me so tired in general that like i i just didn't have the energy to do more slams after that because like it's just a lot of commitment to um like uh i did nephew asked me like oh would i do another slam again and then i was like it really it really depends on the game like i want to be a beginner forever you know i Because I feel like after this,
I don't think Seijam's gonna put me in beginner.
I don't think so.
I don't think he's gonna put me in beginner.
So I want to be a baby forever.
Because if I'm not in beginner, I have to learn so much.
I have to be like diamond or master rank.
That's the thing.
And I don't want to climb the diamond or master.
I can't cheese.
That's it.
You can't cheese and diamond and master Oh, yeah, no, I'm watching the mainstream Guys hype me up on the mainstream guys
Guys, where's my where's my loyal fans?
Let's go Doki.
Yeah, very authentic guys No, I don't think my brain has the source space where jp guys oh yeah don't sorry don't raid the channel don't raid the channel
it's okay it's okay kid is here to represent all of us they're here to represent the dragons the one dragon with the light sticks oh my god literally because of my game we were 10 we were one match ahead of of them that's crazy it literally because of my game that is so much pressure right that is so much pressure oh yeah that's why I didn't want to be last that's why I didn't want to be last oh yeah I was the tiebreaker breaker.
I really was.
Ah, that was the anchor.
I ain't the anchor no more, though.
That's Feisty's job.
Oh, am I the MVP?
That's me!
Yippee!
I did that.
Good shout out to Big Bird and Nephew.
What?
There's no strategy.
I'm playing off of vibes They think I go in with I don't even remember how I won that fight Like legitimately I don't know what my strat is I just play off vibes I adapt on the fly
Yeah I'm just vibing I do something Okay this is my strat If it keeps working I do it again Because then you don't expect me to keep doing it because they're like surely she'll use a different move but like the thing they don't they don't know that um they don't know that i i there's no reason to stop like no way she'll do it the fourth five and then like when they start figuring out then i lock in
Then I start mixing it up by throwing the most random stuff possible.
Yeah.
The no mix up mix up, exactly.
Yeah, they never figured it out.
I change it.
Time to train.
We fight one.
We just fight the Aki.
That's it.
Oh.
When Elite realized that we...
be too late they're gonna realize no i think i think i think i can realize it now that's why i have to swap it up now what other moves does she know they don't know if i don't know they won't know
how would i know guys why are they asking so many questions why are they
asking questions you don't know i don't know the answer to yeah i can play against you the thing is i think she's gonna adapt that's the thing i'm pretty sure she'll adapt like every goddamn fighting game like fgc player like god damn adapting on the fly like adapting in between games god damn it i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure she's gonna change up her playstyle
that's usually how it goes i hate it
yeah they adapt that's cheating i know right there shouldn't be a thing
we should play the same way just play the same way um wait did you guys see the rules they just posted we have to hit 70 points what do you mean 70 how do we get 70.
what does that mean you have to play like new series yeah you just keep playing again like so we'll be home for the first time and then away for the second time and then the third time oh my god that's crazy what that's actually crazy what that's so what that's crazy man we're a winner side like what but you i think it's three times no i guess you got dad fast like more i because we'll have we'll have two sets as home potentially oh yeah that's true or we can just bring it home now in one one and a half set yeah that's true yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my god yeah what's crazy is uh theoretically it there's only 50 points to distribute so you could play a third series yeah oh my god oh my god this is my three times this is gonna last like more five hours bro yeah
yeah whoever goes first is actually a really important person then yeah
so one of the matches is still worth 20.
yeah the third match of every series is still worth 20.
wait does that mean when they're away they can pick someone else to be the 20 pointer yes yeah oh my god so they're probably gonna pick one of y'all good luck guys no god help me okay oh i believe i believe in you i'm not god but i believe in you all right coach queue it up all right i could you want to move to the orientation channel oh okay guys i gotta take my winner p now no more anxiety i feel like that's kind of weird random people be right back i could just go in like our own discord yeah
oh yeah so if you if you knock me down are we safe i'm here uh-huh yeah if you if you knock me down with like your auto light combo you can just dash and do that one yeah or maybe don't maybe don't dash this time it because you have to do the dash immediately if you dash it'll auto-time it oh and let me just
into your yeah you do db yeah
you go into level one if you have it
you're doing it too late but then like don't you have to like wait for the confirm
yeah i can just try blocking yeah
you want to see if i hit or not i don't know if i have the capabilities
definitely can do it it's like maybe the easiest confirm in the game okay thanks for letting me know i don't want to just do this one uh yeah you could do that one too but the other one does more damage than that one the back of you
because the problem is you're guessing right like 20 times to win the round when you do the auto light
you see that does a thousand and the other one does like 24 on you i am back guys it was such a winning pee that i gave dad an extra treat because i feel like a winner so i want you you're gonna be a winner too i'm a winner so you get to be a winner as well i like how we don't even know like we might not even win the grand finals But I'm just like,
I don't care.
I got there.
I know I did my job.
Yeah.
If I'm MVP, you're MVP too.
Oh, Emily down.
Don't worry, I got you.
I'm not.
I like, if I lose to the Aki, I don't care.
like, I did all I could.
Win or lose, I'm already proud of myself.
And maybe do more charged fireballs when she's knocked down, too.
Yeah, I already won.
I already won.
Apparently people were saying, like, it wasn't fair that, like, I was put in the beginner.
But I legitimately thought, I literally thought I was a beginning because i just saw street fighter right after the slap like only lose a few jabs i was i'm i'm sorry i i haven't touched the game for a year plus yeah okay how about the jump thing okay just try yeah yeah jump out like a normal and i learned a new character too do a little later yeah i was i was hard stuck silver for the thing is i was hard stuck silver for gif
Yeah, I changed character
So i was surprised like people were like oh i don't know dorky Maybe not should have been in the beginning you just can't do it too close like try doing it like So i was just like i was like you're a bit farther i was like i swear to god like i was like i swear to god i didn't lie my resume i i even explained it in the in the application i explained it in the application i was like i and them saw street fighter right after the last slam so i don't remember what like i don't remember anything i think she's doing a forward jump but the thing is saratina she was a last minute sub so she jumps out of the because the other player um the other players uh that was originally was in her spot um was was it was like a beginner player i think she was awesome i don't know she was in the slam before but oh my god um but she was also a beginner player but because she dropped out like a day the the day before i think like on tuesday she dropped out on tuesday or wednesday they had to fight an
emergency so like i think because like oh yeah um oh yeah like the um so they got like 13 up for it yeah and then charge up the fireball if you learn you were to join another cjms set and that's beginner you should like i i don't want to be above beginner
that the thing is in diamond to master elop i can't cheese away i can't do knowledge checks because i have to actually run combos and like i think everyone else in the tier above me play classic too.
That's the thing.
They all play classic.
I'm just a filthy modern player.
Like, I'm just, everyone else, no, there's a filthy, everyone else plays, uses a real input.
Yeah.
You can hit master easily, the way you are really you really think so if i look i think if i play this game another day i think i maybe i could get like a higher plan i'm not sure what the maybe i feel like every day every day i like jump up a tier after auto light ones wait
i am a master around 1500 and get knowledge checked all the time like after you land it and you like wait i'm gonna death because they're teaching they're teaching right now.
I mean, it's going to be a while till they're not.
I think they just they have even started the first game, guys.
They haven't even started the first game.
It's going to be a bit.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, but also I uninstalled because the game was 100 gigabytes and I needed my space.
Yeah, they just showed the brackets for the last.
Yeah, that too.
that too the game was 100 gigabytes so i like i was like i need i'm sorry i know i wasn't i always uninstall the games right away after like i'm done with the stream that i know i won't be playing again because like i won't make sure that um um i want you know i want to be sure uh uh oh my gosh i lost my train of thought i wish i had space i have space sorry i saw something funny on twitter i'm literally like i'm i'm twitter scrolling that's how chill i'm at right now
that's how um that's how chill max that maxing i am
yeah train us not not after this damn
bum no no
have all right give me a sec guys i gotta find it again i didn't bookmark it oh no guys i don't know if i have oh i don't know oh i refreshed it guys guess we'll never see oh wait it's this i see it i love this panel oh wait i don't think i can show it on stream but this comic panel it's one of my favorite it's one of my favorite oh and this one too and this
back to back DC shit right there
I was like I was like what do you mean there's a there's a version that was too gay
that it's apparently a comic cover with um they're not no they're in their swimsuits guys but also why i know i was like there's a gayer version oh also i'd bookmark this okay i bookmark some funny tweets to if i ever want to show it to stream and this is one of them i love this one too I love this sweet.
It's reacting time.
We have an hour to kill.
I can react if I want to.
Honestly, that is a killer line.
I can't believe he ghosted her right after this.
That is such a good line.
That is wife material.
I can show this.
Wait a minute.
That's not five feet of fire.
Many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you That is a good the fact that he ghosted her right after doesn't know what he missed out on But the kind of attitude is what I love As someone that loves bread
Nah she right yeah it's honest it's honest and it's good it's a good line also I need to show the screenshot again that's why i said i didn't expect myself to go this far i love this i was like um i don't get to platfield they figure out my three moves so now i'm hard stuck never mind i went on a seven game win streak
yeah it's just like never mind jk Wait, I'm goaded, yeah.
We're like, you went too weird to hope, Corey.
Just whoopsing the flat.
Why can't you go on it?
Because I have to rely on other people.
In this, I can only rely on myself.
Oh, yeah, I got the, yeah, mine's the cat ear.
Yeah, I have the cat ear.
if you if you get added by a dokey braid that's a scam account yeah because street fight only has one person's throat i am my own e-o-m-m agent in any other game i have several but in this game i am my own agent that's how it goes
um I'm
just chilling.
Just looking through Twitter.
I'm just I'm bottom bottom bottom bottom bottom bottom bottom bottom
bottom bottom bottom
oh all right let's watch the game
i once ran into bravo on street fighter 6 rank while he's streaming and he spent the whole match calling me old okay but what character were you playing though i'm so chill max guys right now i have to give a super chat thank you thank you all right who's winning oh my god it's jury oh this is jury versus um ryu
Oh my god, it's just, it's literally just, everyone is just bad.
I just realized everyone's just,
yeah, were you playing JP-I-I are you winning?
Yay, thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I am, I am, I won all my matches so far.
At this point, like, I'm legitimately, like, even if I lose the next matchup, like i'm fine with that um because i did i think i like i didn't expect myself to do well so i'm i'm chill like that i'm just happy i'm just happy yeah
um oh no oh no
bro this music is actually it's like whoever everyone's just randomly see i told you it's the di strat guys it works burnout and keep going burnout is so strong no i don't think i can sneak another game because like it's just like we're on like capcom stuff too i told you look at that look at see they're all just keep burning out until until it's over it just works it just works it just works yeah it's like music for me right now it really is oh yeah I should put it put on the um put on OBS for those who are like where's our game I'm sorry let me put it on let me put it on I'm not grabbing food made it to finals so we are waiting for our game There you go.
And it's in comic sense, too.
So you know we're serious.
Alright, here you go.
I know I should be...
I know I should warm up, but like we have so much time to warm up, guys.
We have so much time.
i definitely will not be streaming rivals tonight guys this is a lot
there's like we got away for a while
also because of the noise complaint oh yeah by the way i didn't get confronted because by the time i finished stream because i did like my finished stream and then like um got my like did my uh upstream like routine thing um i went to to the door and then like the whoever was knocking on my door was gone
so um yeah i saw i did not stall guys i had to do my goodbye also i am getting tired guys it was bad thing is like i am getting tired like
oh i'm getting hot pot tonight for sure I think by the time this whole thing ends I think hot pot's the only thing that's open I feel like if I take a nap and come back it won't it still won't be my turn
no it's just the adrenaline the thing is like I started that I started today with so much adrenaline and anxiety that like you know like when you have so much no I'm gonna head to a restaurant I'm going outside.
I'm going to, that's right.
I'm going to go out.
That's how, how happy I am today.
I know it's wild.
I'm going to go outside.
A victory feast.
Yeah.
Is it the, one of the self-service hot pot places too?
Who are you?
you right after this is done um but what was i talking oh yeah but i have there was so much adrenaline and anxiety going and you know it didn't help that my controller wasn't working either
so i had so much adrenaline anxiety um everything going into the tournament after you know we your grand finals you know all of it just flowed out yeah it all just flowed out and now I'm just so chill yeah it took no no I know I fumbled you guys saw that I couldn't even do the headbutt like I don't I couldn't even I couldn't even do the headbutt chat because of it because I was like oh my god I'm a controller yeah and then like she got like half my HP from it
Yeah, my first move.
Yeah.
Oh, the first round was very shaky.
Yeah, and then I hit button.
And then I realized, but I was like, wait a minute, she burns out.
You know what that means.
Yippee, though.
Yippee, yippee, yippee.
And then bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom.
Which Brian clip?
Wait, which one?
There's so many clips.
Guys, I can't keep track of my clips.
I always do stupid things.
Like, you gotta know, you gotta be very specific.
What stupid thing did I do this time?
face oh yeah this is what i said it's been funny oh yeah i don't yeah i couldn't tell wait i know what she's gonna do brian wait i don't know what she's doing
i don't know what to expect brian i have an idea wait wait wait okay wait where's this clip That sounds good.
Wait, someone tag, post it on bird, like, birdseater.
Someone get a clip and post it on birdseater.
And then, um, oh, birdseater.
Wait, I don't know my own tags.
That's how chill I am.
Yeah, birdseaters.
Post it in birdseater so I can, um, so I can, so we can link it on Twitter.
Right at the start of, oh, when I, my controller DCed and he was like, what am, what am I?
oh it was after that i was gonna say was he confused that i didn't move
oh the actual start okay oh yeah when like when uh oh when i fumbled my inputs and burnt out Yeah, because I was that's I was so nervous What is my stress strats?
Yeah, when I messed up my one button.
I told you I was I was so nervous I was so nervous that's how now I was like oh my gosh as I didn't I was like oh my gosh I'm gonna be this and I have to be the 20-pointer too and then finding out I have to be the 20-pointer I
it like it messed with me
am i still nervous um no i'm more relaxed now because i don't at that point like for me it doesn't matter we got first or second because like i did my job you know
bro i yeah they should i they should have made me surprised i'd be like why am i playing another game like i was just like why am i playing another They should have done that.
They should have, like, kept it a surprise.
And then I'd be like, why am I playing another game?
Is it not over?
And...
They should have done that for me.
Because that added on, too.
They should have kept me in the dark.
I'll be like, I'm the...
I have to do another set.
Also, I realized.
Because, like...
technically like if you think about it I think Dom or was it Dom's team they had a better advantage because I don't actually let's see because like two teams get to have two teams get the home advantage because we had home advantage twice but depending on the matchups because like we couldn't get home if I feel like we would have being in the lead if um we oh wait no we won it it would have been a lot easier no we did win our home advantage never mind i was gonna say it would have been a lot easier if they put me in the 20 points against the other two players yeah oh every team got home advantage twice oh okay but you know what i mean like um uh if it wasn't against the aki and we get home advantage for the Ryu and the jury,
it would be less stressful for my team, for sure.
Yeah.
I feel like it would have been a lot stressful.
Because, like, even though I know I was not feeling the 20-pointer, the match would have been a lot easier.
It went, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, we probably shared better.
Oh, posted a video on the tag?
All right, let's see.
All right.
Here's the Twitter.
Here's the tweet.
And they're like, wait, what?
That was nervous!
Look, okay, right after I was feeling the groove after this.
that i started off i started off with the crap because i missed something but that was nervous i was so anxious
it was an
oopsie yeah it was just an oopsie i i confused them and then they were everyone got confused no one knows my mind even i don't know my mind it was to send a message exactly no one no yeah yeah i knew it was so free that i had to do that grab
but um but um yeah it was her yeah it was all planned
Just chilling.
Sorry, I'm not talking too much, guys.
I'm just really chilling now.
Oh, yeah.
There's some quality geef right now.
Ah, yes, Zane geef.
I think I would have struggled even harder if I had to play Zane geef against this matchup.
Because everyone was, you know, like, everyone countered me everyone technically counters honda but the other players countered zankeef harder yeah yeah so i feel like i felt like even though i did play zankeef it would i would have an even rougher time i went against juri aki and ryu and um and all of like you know i had It's all about trying to get there.
Like, yeah.
Yeah, and Honda can just, you know, headbutt.
Okay.
You hate the Honda matchup as Aki?
I hate fighting Aki's, too, in rank.
Um, I don't know.
I hate fighting all three of those players, like, all those three of those characters as Honda.
I think the easiest character to be as Honda...
In my Ilo, in my Ilo was Jamie.
Every time I see a Jamie, I'm like, and, and, um, and Akuma.
Uh, Akuma slash Bison, because they like to use Drive Impact a lot.
They like to use DUI, so I can, I can just, like, headbutt infinitely.
That's every Ilo.
That's every Ilo for Jamie.
Yeah.
have to stick our one or could you choose you can choose any character but you know a lot some of these players are new so they just play their mains yeah everyone just plays their mains because you know well to be fair i was technically i didn't want to play gif there because like i heard gif got nerfed so i was just like bro bro and then i saw i was asking like nephew like do you know who what they're playing and nephew was like oh yeah like um um one of them was an aki And then I was like,
yeah, I'm not playing Gif.
Because, like, I remember in the stage I'm slam, Aki was, like, the one I struggled the most because I had to change my tempo.
I had to change the tempo of how I play.
So I was like, I'm not playing him.
Like, like, freak that.
Yeah, I wanted an easier time for this tournament.
too.
I just want to be like headfoot.
Yeah, and it was the same.
And I saw it was like the same one too.
Because like, I remember like I remember like Saratina had a really rough time in the slam.
Because she was playing classic.
She was like one of the her and was it Saikuna were the only players trying to play classic in the beginner level.
I remember I like when I had the Zangiefs sweep um during one of the group stages like you know i did really well in um i did really well during i think like day two um but seratina's akki was the hardest matchup for me it was the hardest fight for me because like um i was super aggressive for the other against the other opponents but the akki had to change my tempo and so i had to like play a lot slower and that sucks for me um I hate playing really slow when I'm on Zangief But on Honda,
it's a lot easier to play super slow Yeah
Yeah, because on Honda, I can play slow and fast at the same time Like I can adapt to be slower fast But on Zangief, I could play fast I was able to get away with playing super fast And just, like, just go attack, attack, attack In rank and also in practice because people didn't expect that.
Like, you know, like, the higher you go, the more passive Zen Gif players are.
So people didn't expect me to go, like, hard aggression on Gif.
Because if I make my first move and never let them have the move next, like, they're already dead because the grapples were so strong.
But then, like, when I had to play against the Aki, I had to be, like, I had to be the slowest player ever.
It was so tilting for me.
It was just, it was, it was like super frustrating and I did not enjoy it.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was not enjoyable.
So I like that for Honda.
No, I have to wait for a while.
It's now the third match now.
But for Honda, it was a lot easier to adapt to fast and slow.
it was easier to react to like to change my play style on Honda how much longer I think it'll be an hour before we begin I'm pretty sure I think it's going to be a while guys
it's going to take a bit
yeah I'm just looking through Twitter right now
Um Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum
Um Well They're not really I mean it's just their make way I mean it's the third game They just have to hit 50 points They're at Guys Oh my god They're I'm so tempted to end stream And then come back part two of the tournament bro i just have to wait oh my god they're both at 10 points and then they have to get the 50 oh my god i didn't think this through all right and that's the way for another set
oh my god i wasn't thinking this through guys no i shouldn't the thing is i don't know about i don't think i'm allowed to play anything else i think i'm just by the way the thing is like um they were even like please don't play copyright music like to us too they're like please stop don't play copyright music because we're they're supposed to pull videos off of our own stream too um off of our stream too so like i don't want to get in trouble
no it wasn't there wasn't a contract i just showed up
What do we do to burn time bro?
I don't know.
Do I just make a part two?
What if I just make a part two waiting room?
No.
Because I don't know how long I'll be waiting for it.
Well, I shouldn't be, I shouldn't be in trouble.
I'm just waiting for my finals.
I do not, I'm not gonna nap.
I'm just hanging out.
I don't want to, the thing is, I don't want to warm up.
um I don't want to spend like two hours warming up because then I get way too tired because that happens to me when I like um you know like when you're playing rank and then like you get worse as you play because obviously like you get you know you get fatigue from rank um I'll definitely drink some coffee though right but like before my game because I am feeling tired yeah so like I don't want to I'll warm up an hour before uh just restream the thing is I need to set that up I usually set that up before a stream,
but I did not do that.
So I'd rather just wait, like, and out.
Like, I guess, like, when the second bracket starts, I'll warm up.
Because I think, like, legitimately, I'm pretty sure, like, IDOM's team is just gonna sweep it.
Like, sweep the semis.
I'm pretty sure.
Because the only team they struggled with was us.
So I'm pretty sure they'll just sweep the...
I would be very surprised if...
Because like the...
The matchups are very...
I mean they're very close too.
They're very close.
But when they were...
But like I feel like it's between Nephew and Idom team versus...
We're close.
Our skill level is close.
But Brian and...
is not like they are like um they're like um like they're the other the two they're close together but uh yeah did we struggle i don't remember i didn't struggle i was fine
I had a good time.
Oh, no.
The ego's back.
On the start, Arcade mode.
No, like I said, I don't want to, I don't want to, like, play too much.
It was tougher for the others.
Yeah, that's why I'm saying, I don't want to be a beginner.
That's why, like, I don't want to know about doing a Z-Jamp slam for Street Fighter.
Because, like, because if I had to, another they won't put me in beginner if i have to be in a different tier i ain't chill i ain't chilling i literally played nine hours of honda in the last three days because like the thing is i found out i was gonna be in the um uh the capcon tournament thing like a week before it was announced so technically i could have i found out about it on the 22nd guys that was gonna be in the in the capcon tournament i waited until this week tuesday to practice to install the game
i wouldn't be able to do that if i was in a different tier guys i wouldn't guys i would not have been able to do that if i was in a different tier also it's because like um I think like all the FGC players were traveling to somewhere.
We're watching.
We're traveling to where was it?
To there was a street fighter tournament around that time when it got announced.
I don't even remember what it's called.
But everyone's like traveling.
So because like I asked Nephew like, oh like when can we get like a coaching session?
And Nephew was like, oh, I'll be back on Tuesday.
But like if you want, we could.
Like, I'll be back on Monday, so we could do it a day earlier, too.
Because I was thinking, like, oh, should I start?
Because I knew, like, I needed a coaching session.
It wouldn't matter if I just opened the game without a coach, you know?
Because it's, like, I don't know what I'm doing.
Like, I don't understand fighting games.
So, like, I had to wait for, like, coaches to be available.
And, like, at that time, like, Nephew was, like, I'm still traveling.
I'll be back around, I'll be back around, like, Monday.
So I was just like, I'll just wait Tuesday.
because like Tuesday we're supposed to be like broadcast on this channel anyway and then um and then you know Justin was like traveling too for with his family as well so I was like oh I'll just yeah I'll just wait on Tuesday then like I also I think I think that if I if I got earlier coaching I think people will complain more Because I'm pretty sure I'd be A lot higher ranked Like I would show up being diamond or something In the beginning level I'd just be like the Honda and diamond And against a rookie I think people would be very mad So I could Yeah I think they would put me in the They would swap in with someone else I think Yeah,
absolutely.
If I didn't play Marvel Rivals instead of in Sub-Street Fighter.
Yeah, it worked out.
I just showed up as Platt.
No, I think, like, the fact that Sir Tina's in it and not, like, the person that she filled in, I think people will be very mad.
Because, you know, I'm very sad because the other player is also new, too.
So, like, I would actually, at least, like, you know, 13 hour, both the same rank.
Because I don't know what Elo, the other person, the person she was placing was.
So I feel like, yeah, I feel like I, people would be not happy about that.
I didn't think I would pick it up so fast, guys.
You don't understand.
I didn't think I'd pick up how to play this video game so fast.
yeah i legitimately thought i was like i don't know maybe i lied to myself but i legitimately thought i was beginner level just because like um i felt like i i don't retain information long term very well um and um and i was like learning a new character too maybe i'm just a fast learner i could be
maybe i mean i feel like i'm just i i mean i am like a fast learner in general.
I just learned very fast.
I think it's just from my experience in FPS games too.
Yeah.
I think it was just, it's just like, just the knowledge transfer from FPS games.
So I have to react very fast in general.
Um, because like the other, the thing is, the other two because like, you know, we have like FPS players in this tournament that just picked up, like Karkew.
Karkew was, is a top 500 Overwatch player, and I think like he was beginner like he was beginner tier in the sage i'm slam and then now he's like in master yeah now he's like in master the thing about that makes me different from me and the other fps players that joined sage i'm slam they kept playing i i i sort of uninstalled
yeah also i can't do combos too i kind of do combos you can try and force it in my head but i won't be able to understand
you won't yeah you i won't be i do my auto combos it's all about auto here that's why when i see the beginner players try to use uh use like uh classic i'm just like bro Power to you.
All the power to you.
Maturasu, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Yoki, you're born natural and neutral.
Most people are thinking meter, thinking drag, thinking combos.
You just think, I bet they won't see this coming, lol.
And that makes you perfect for grapplers and big bodies.
You're fine just the way you are.
You mean they think five steps ahead?
I'm legitimately thinking as I go.
Sometimes I'm not thinking.
What the heck combos?
What is that?
What is that even me?
Yeah, exactly.
That's why I'm perfect for...
That's why I'm perfect for the beginner level.
Where are they at now?
Okay, they're at their fourth match now.
Okay, so they just need to win.
Brian's team just need to win two games.
And it does, I don't know if it looks like that.
I don't know.
I swear to God, if it gets to 40-40, I swear to God.
Yeah, no, Brian's team.
I don't know.
He just got a perfect KO.
Beckman just got a perfect KO, guys.
Oh, yeah, this is also why, like, I watched the 2X KO stream.
Um, and, like, and, and, like, bro, like, it feels like the combo lasts 20 years.
Like, the moment you get hit by one combo, you're just dead.
I was watching it.
Like, I was watching the 2xKO slam.
It felt so scary.
Like, you have to be aware.
For anyone that plays the 2xKO...
Yeah, it felt like an infinite combo.
Like, yeah.
You have seen nothing yet.
It felt...
Yeah, it was like...
And then, like, the tag...
And then you have to be aware of, like, whenever they're going to use the tag team.
But different tag teams have different...
like high low medium hit too um
that was like techin not how i play techin
not how i play there was no auto moves in techin for me
yeah they were doing duos too they were doing duos as well i heard like official 2x ko tournaments started banning Timo because of how not fun.
Like, Timo and Echo, right?
I don't remember.
They banned, like, I think they were trying to do, like, tournaments without Timo and Echo because, like, they were, like, super oppressive or something.
So, I saw that on Twitter.
Good.
Do you guys see the Avatar?
The Avatar fighting game that got released and everyone was, like, chit-talking it?
To be fair, like...
Yes, it's like animated, but like...
It felt like they did it in Flash.
You know what I'm saying?
They felt like they were... It wasn't like...
Like, it wasn't hand-drawn.
It felt like they were using like...
You know, like Flash rigging and stuff.
No, it's not out.
It just...
Uh...
Yeah, it just...
I don't know.
It just looks weird.
Yeah, it looks like flash games that you can find on the Cartoon Network site.
It got announced and stuff, and they showed, like, I just wish it looked better.
I wish it was done.
It was animated better.
Yeah, it looked, oh yeah, it looked like Game of Newgrounds.
I would say that.
Because, like, I mean, it is pretty exciting.
And then it looked like Aang could only airbend, while Korra had, like, all the elements and stuff.
like it's like 30 FPS that's what it looks like that's what the avatar fighting game looks like and then there's like what the invincible tag team one I think it was funny that they made an invincible fighting game because 80% of the roster is just the same powers and then there's what's the name there's the um there's the the see the And then there's CISO with his teleport.
The guy that's using government funding to teleport.
Using your taxpayer.
Payers money.
His powers is literally money.
Money go.
Oh my god.
It's 30.
I swear to God.
If they get to.
If they.
Okay.
What team Brian needs to do.
It's literally just when they're.
uh our rounds will you match up yeah i saw that i saw the tweet where they were figuring out what uh how much is combos cost and actual money oh my god i don't know if i should keep talking because i'm getting tired more tired i'm getting tired from just talking
oh because i'm using my brain i know it's wild Maybe I should get coffee.
I should only get coffee.
Oh.
The rest of you need to.
I don't want to end stream.
Oh, end stream.
No.
We just vibe.
I wish I could show the stream on my screen.
But I can't because I haven't set that option.
I should have set it up.
I didn't think.
I didn't think it would be that long.
I didn't think it would take this long
Oh yeah I didn't finish my chocolate Let me finish my chocolate My 50-90, oh my god, my chocolate's melting.
I'm eating the...
Mmm.
I'm eating the Kinder Surprise.
Um, not the egg, but the little bars.
I love those bars.
Every time I...
I don't eat it often.
I just spoil myself if I feel what I deserve it.
Today I deserve it.
Hmm.
How much longer till finals?
A lot longer.
Wait, did Team Brian win?
Wait, how?
Wait, what?
What happened?
No, they're still going.
Okay.
Oh, no, they still have one.
No, not even.
No, they haven't won yet.
That's to hit 50 points, guys.
They haven't won yet.
No.
They just need one more game.
Team Brian just need a win.
One more game.
And then they advance.
Yeah.
It's 30-20.
I was gonna say, how?
I was like, not how, I was like, how did Team Brian win?
But, like, I was like, I know I'm bad at math, but I'm pretty sure they still need to do another game.
Yeah, I was gonna...
Yeah, I was like, I was like, I'm pretty sure they have...
Even if they, Brian, Team, won that game, you have to do one more game.
So, yeah, that's why I was, like, so confused.
I was, like, what do you mean they won?
no they need 50 so literally team brian needs to win the next match and then they make it in and then they're in
i think i think team brian would advance just because like their team is actually pretty good but the one thing that um is holding them the one thing is that idom's team is a lot more um scarier it's a lot scarier versus uh um god it sucks to play zangief now look how slow he's walking over he's just slowly walking over intimately yeah
so wait this oh yeah they need two more games yeah brian needs two more games
oh i'll create a lobby i won't talk about what's going on But you guys can watch You guys I'll give you guys something to watch You're right I could do that Don't worry I'll give you guys something to watch I might not commentate but At least you guys can watch something Yeah the Dragoon The Dragoon fight pit
Wouldn't it be better I mean, theoretically, yes.
It's also Capcom's...
Wait, no, this is not the first time.
The last time they did this, it was three teams instead of...
Yeah, bring out your freak fighters.
The first time they did this...
Oh, yeah, for those who don't know, just search up.
Search up, not D Honda.
We are waiting for our...
Okay, guys, don't start it yet.
We are waiting...
Made it to finals.
So we are waiting for a game.
For now, we watch Dragoons fight.
Search up not the Honda to join room.
There we go.
Let me put this to one line and then...
Wait, how far does this go?
There we go.
Search up to join room.
All right, there you go.
All right, let's watch Aki versus Aki.
All right, this is going to be like Zoom.
Oh, my God, Aki versus Aki.
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Oh, oh, they were waiting.
Oh, what the heck?
Okay, there you go.
Oh, you guys don't see the HP.
Oh, my God, where do I put this?
Here?
Yeah, we'll watch it here.
There we go.
You guys watch this fight.
I'm going to look at Twitter.
Yeah, which Aki do you think is going to win?
Guys, I have to save my energy.
I'm getting tired.
I'm getting EP.
Oh, bro.
Here I'm here.
I got you the iPad dragoons
Here you go.
I got you guys the iPad Yeah, entertain yourself Now you can entertain each other
Oh Brian won the next game
Brian needs to win one more game to progress
Wow, did you see...
What?
Yeah, I saw the sick tweet right now.
I saw the sick tweet.
All right, I'll put up a poll next fight.
Average millennial coaching.
Are they still going?
This is a different level.
I'm like, wait, they're still going.
It's the same match.
Oh my god.
Of course, yeah, I have feeling Mastery when I was gonna win.
They're still going.
That was a long one.
Wow.
I can't believe Aki won.
The Aki won against the Aki.
Whoa.
Get what you get, guys.
No charges.
Fun,
fun, fun, fun, fun.
Oh shit, the diamond got him round.
I actually looked up from Twitter I looked to my other bond nerd I'm watching your match on my OBS
Fight for our entertainment
Oh yeah Wait I should write Made it to finals So we are waiting For our game For now we watched dragoons fight search up not wait who won the diamond did the diamond one
honor to join room oh my god okay not okay there you go those who are confused i have to type this out to let people know what i'm doing People won't be confused.
My Magnum Opus!
Oh my god, final round!
Okay.
Got you.
Vanished.
No infantile.
Happy.
Try not to run.
K-O.
Aki.
Wins.
K-O.
Yay!
Oh, Team Brighton also won!
That's good.
They did it.
Oh, the diamond won again?
Good for you.
All right, we'll start warming up after the first game.
All right, who do we watch next?
Master Honda versus Challenger Terrier.
Oh, this one... Oh, wait.
Round... Wait, this one seems good.
I want to watch this.
Okay, I mean, you guys want to watch this.
Oh, this one seems like a good matchup.
Alright.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Alright, you guys watch this.
I go watch other things.
Okay.
Why is that all...
I bet like...
I bet Sartina has been like...
Labbing against me.
And I'm just here...
Doom scrolling, Twitter.
I bet she's been labbing against me the last like hour or so.
Oh, she's not?
Is she or is she not?
She's much more dedicated.
Oh, she was labbing earlier?
I'll lab, I'll lab like an hour before, like I'll lab after the first game.
Just practicing how to parry headbutts.
Okay, that's good to know.
That's good to know.
She's gonna be so surprised.
Oh, for a bit, but not for a dog.
Oh, she was?
Okay.
I was gonna say, because I know she does a lot of labbing.
I like asked I remember like I asked my coaches, nephew and big bros like what do I do against these people and then they were like they you know they don't you know like usually a normal coach would like bring you to the custom room and then they like show you what you do against those people they wrote to me what to do and then I didn't retain any of that.
I didn't retake anything.
That's why I say I'm playing as I go.
I'm literally just playing as I go.
Because I was like, what do I do against like this?
And then they're like, oh, you do this, this, this.
I'm like, not a hotel.
But they don't know.
It was not no.
No,
not to hold on.
Yeah, it was not who hold on.
Not not who hold on.
I
see.
She doesn't see.
Jokes on them.
I don't know how to read.
Round two.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Damn.
I looked over.
Oh, shit.
Fight back.
Yay, my...
You're still going?
Wait.
When does it end?
Wait, what's the score currently for them?
Oh, yeah, I forgot it, but sorry iPad kids.
I forgot to bring the pull.
There's an ending.
We'll do it for the next one.
Oh, it's 1-1?
Huh?
Whoa!
With the my wins!
Let's go!
Beautiful women wins again.
Damn, she was cooking.
Alright.
Oh man, we have to watch this.
Master Aki versus Master whatever he is.
He's not a cute girl, so like, I don't even know his name.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay, there you go.
DBC moment right here he can be we don't even know his name he's not a cute girl
I can't wait for my hot pot you
know what yeah I'm looking forward to like my hot pot that's it I mean it'll be cool if we won but you know it'd be cooler hot pot after this
Wait, how do you know I'm shaking my leg?
Wait, how do you guys know?
Are you talking about the game?
No, I'm going out, guys.
That's how motivated I am.
I'm going to go outside to the hot pot.
Oh, is it because I'm switching on screen?
Okay, yo.
I think my teammates are laughing.
Wait.
Are my teammates laughing?
I don't know.
As they should be.
Yay!
Yaki!
Beautiful women wins again.
Everyone trained.
Man, these memes are pretty funny.
Ta-girls.
Tiger, tiger, tiger.
I definitely will get coffee after this.
Wait, I'm going to check my coffee store.
My coffee shop is...
Because either that or I get Game Yourself's, but I'd rather just get coffee instead.
I think Game Yourself makes my heart...
Like, Game Yourself's good, but like, for that, it makes my heart be too fast when I'm anxious.
And I know I'm going to...
I know, like, even though I'm relaxed right now, I know I'll be anxious later.
doesn't get my heart beating that as fast as being yourselves.
That's just caffeine.
Caffeine just does that.
But the thing is, like, when I'm, you know, obviously, like, that's just what caffeine does in general.
Like, if I'm, like, like, you just get, like, zoned in, you know?
And, like, I'm an anxious person in general.
So, like, uh, so, like, I need, like, C-Man has entered the room.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Yo, let's go, C-Man.
Oh my god, the non-beautiful woman won?
What is this?
What?
All right.
I don't know if, like, okay, should we watch an Iron Player versus a Platte?
Oh, we should watch this.
Honda versus...
Or you guys should watch this.
The bison versus the Honda.
Tucky.
Respect your elder.
Oh my god, the slap butt.
What a slap butt.
Oh yeah, I keep forgetting.
Okay, we'll make the pull.
We'll make the pull for the next game.
And then she never made the pull.
Okay, we'll make the pull for the next game.
No, Sivan, why did you leave?
I don't know if I should...
Okay, when should I get the caffeine, guys?
When the match is starting or when it gets closer?
What do you think is best for me to have caffeine?
Now?
or later now okay i'm gonna go get a calf i'm gonna go downstairs to buy caffeine i'll be right back guys be
right back getting caffeine i should write that down let me make write that down real quick so people know brb getting caffeine i don't know if i spelled it right i don't care enough to wait where is my text
yeah i'll be back
m bison wins round one fight
You are barely worth the effort.
Round 2.
Fight.
I'm too slow.
Finger again.
Kill your eyes!
Error.
Quick move!
It's over!
Prepare!
Now let's send this!
Final round!
Fight it!
Get along to this!
No escape!
Take your capture!
To the truth!
To kill!
Errogyt!
It's over!
Prepare!
Mind!
your time ends here be gone m bison wins round one fight new escape
Round two, fight it
over.
M.
Bison wins.
Round one, fight it.
Spirit.
Arrogant fool.
It's over.
Errogant fool.
All right.
Take your mind.
Here's some beast.
Gotcha.
All right.
Here's some beast.
Gotcha.
Come on, spirit!
K-O!
Round two.
Fight!
Destroy your mind!
Boom!
It's over!
Prepare!
That's it!
Lift!
No escape!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Beg for your life!
Need breath?
Destroy!
Come here!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Come on!
Fight!
I don't
Round one Fight Your defense stinks No escape You are a bore No escape You are
it's over your mind
kill kill inherited prepare splurge
round two fight yeah no kill kill kill your mind
kill Find this!
Try it!
I can't!
I shall throw!
You are a boy!
Too slow!
Don't try!
Too much spirit!
Honda wins!
Round one, fight.
Your mind pointless.
Errigen fool.
It's over.
Too slow.
Your mind.
You.
Get along to this.
Nightmare.
Ha ha ha.
Show me your word.
Round two, fight.
Too much spirit.
Don't mind.
Too slow.
No escape.
Jack.
Direct your mind.
Gotcha.
Amateur.
No skill!
Come on!
Fight time!
No
time!
No time!
Okay, oh!
Good sign this!
Final round!
Fight!
Ready!
Prepare!
Change again!
Unremarked!
Double kill!
Is that all right?
No escape!
Honda wins!
Too slow!
Put out!
Fight!
Kill!
K-O!
Honda wins!
Fight!
Oh!
Too slow!
This is it.
You hungry?
You will rule this day.
Psycho, Punisher, K-O,
show me.
me your worth I will tame you in due time round two fight
gotcha that's it come here all
right no escape
here You're an arrogant fool!
Too slow!
No stakes!
You...
Yeah!
Your sky!
Final round!
Fight me!
You are a boy.
Unremarkable.
Can I prepare?
You are a boy.
Unremarkable.
Honda wins!
Round one.
Fight.
No escape!
Come on, spirit!
Immunize!
This is
it!
Hit him!
That's him!
Your mind!
Boom!
Hit him!
Where you going?
K-O!
Hit him!
Round two.
Fight.
Are they still dead?
Oh my god.
I'm back.
Sorry.
I'm I'm back now.
There was a really long line.
Oh, were you What's going on?
What was going on?
Oh, it's 10-10.
What was even going on?
You missed the It never It's not Oh,
I'm missing that
We're watching Pete Okay All right, it's time to warm up Okay guys, we gotta warm up now Okay All right, I got my caffeine All right, I leave Stop spec Give me a room Give me a room right now I need the room.
Also, pick our key.
We need our keys.
But there's a long line.
I also forgot about my laundry.
So I had to fix that.
I forgot about my laundry.
This is a Dragon TV show now.
Move.
I need an hockey.
Get out.
Bro, when do I have, when did I, oh my god, I had so many master players watching my stream.
Are you guys having fun watching whatever the heck I've been doing?
Like, hmm.
Also, I messed up and I asked for a hot caramel latte.
No, I asked for a caramel latte, but forgot to be specific and said iced caramel latte and they made it.
So I, you know.
They made it, so, um, so I was just like, oh, well, you're not in Aki!
I'm only fighting Aki's, guys.
Yeah, so it's a hot here, Malate.
No, ice is better because it's so hot in my room right now.
I'm hoping it kicks in.
Ah.
That's right, they never dodged this for some reason.
I don't know why.
There we go.
Ha ha ha ha!
My side now, bitch.
It's okay, they're not watching, I think.
What I noticed is that she...
She grabs...
She grabs, like, after two strikes, which I've noticed.
Look at that.
adapting now and then she's not gonna do that after it wouldn't be funny if she doesn't do that oh oh oh my god I don't understand how are you getting away with it there you go now you're not oh no my super head butt there you go that's right it'll be a shape nope oh oh never mind never mind never mind oh oh she grabs after that
that's right no one ever expects that oh nice no one expects that either hell yeah that's right wait don't move anyway don't move yet don't move yet i'm drinking my caramel Oh, Latte, stop, stop.
She doesn't expect that!
Oh, wait, he did.
I can't believe he expected that.
Get it.
Oh, my God.
He expected it.
Who would have thought?
No one expects this.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
When they start expecting it, it's like, what's the point, you know?
Oh, oh.
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh!
That's right.
Don't know why people don't expect that.
Makes me confused.
You know?
Oh, okay.
Unlucky.
Round two.
Fight.
Oh.
Alright, nice.
That's right.
My turn!
Watch my cutscene!
I can drink my latte while we watch.
Enough time to drink.
Fucking dirty.
It's cutscene time.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Oh.
Oh my god.
You're such a...
You're such a bitch.
Oh my god.
Bro, this is too slow.
Stop.
I don't like it.
I really like how slow he's playing.
It makes me mad.
I don't like how slow he's playing.
All right.
Where's my next Aki?
All right, Brian, let's go.
Look, I gotta play against different Aki's, guys.
I forgot.
Guys, if you guys can play just like her, just like the Aki I'm playing against.
I would really appreciate it.
That's right.
oh that's right that's right jump again oh you're too scared to jump now right haha that's right oh my god I shouldn't jump though jumping is a mistake what get out in this corner.
Get out of here.
Stop.
Okay.
Can't do this forever.
Oh, she can.
Oh, my gosh.
She can keep doing it forever.
My turn.
Oh my gosh, you need to stop jumping for it.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm trying to, like...
Alright.
Brick this.
Cutscene.
Enough time to drink.
Drink my coffee.
Stop!
Get out of here!
Watch my cutscene!
All right.
Hold on.
There you go.
I should have used the entire there.
I don't know why people don't do anything about that.
Oh my god.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's right.
I'm on the other side now.
Get sit down.
There we go.
Sit down.
Do you like how I jumped to the other side?
Here
we go.
Slam!
Oh, you didn't expect that, did you?
Neither did I!
Coffee time!
Coffee break!
There we go.
I got my coffee break.
Bro, master?
Okay, wait, yeah, whatever.
IPG, wait, did I fight IPG yet?
Was the IPG the one I fought?
I don't know.
Because we fought a diamond.
Oh my god, it's 20 to 30.
Not yet?
No?
Okay.
Oh, wait, I'm spectating.
Wait, what?
Get out.
May, it's my turn.
Okay, I fought Brian.
I thought you guys were talking about, like, the matches.
Yeah, I'm sipping it.
I'm just, like, casually sipping it.
I'm not, like, chugging it.
Oh, oh, versus first.
Oh, the D I counter
Get out My turn
My turn Oh, I messed it up Your turn, your turn, your turn, your turn, your turn Your turn
Oh Oh Oh, I knew she does She's good at counter DIs I don't know why I thought it would be different this time I thought she would mess it up You know I was like truly she won't do it a second time, you know, but I was like, maybe she won't do it a second time
Oh my god, I need to do anti-air there
There we go, my turn I don't care I want her to watch this Coffee time
Coffee time.
No, I have to watch her cutscene.
Oh, no.
She made me watch her cutscene.
I didn't expect that.
No!
She would...
I can't believe she predicted it.
How could she know I would jump?
How- how did she know?
Also take a sip of your coffee.
Look, she is diamond, so me getting it that close, I take this.
The fact that it was that close, you know?
Oh Right
There you go Okay Oh my god.
I can't believe I got that block in.
I wasn't expecting that.
Oh.
Unlucky.
Get to the wall!
Get to the other side!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Ah, I knew she was gonna do that too.
There we go.
That's right.
You can't grab me a second.
second time unless like that mix up oh my gosh oh my god oh my god when does this combo end now I say when it's gonna end oh my gosh oh yes you missed oh my god yes not that's right no that's not right
Oh, that sounded like I thought I was close enough.
Oh my god, that's throw.
I need to remember when she does the jab.
She wants to throw me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, no, I could have antedited that.
That's fine.
Could attempt, you know.
I got punished.
Alright, let me see.
where they're at now 20 to 30 god it's kind of okay i just need to win
okay wait i wish i know who's on whose team oh home oh home is the purple okay so brawlpo just has to win this one
hmm i mean it's close well i'm gonna watch this because that'll be 30 30 And whoever wins there...
Oh, this is so close, guys.
This is so close.
But his Japanese curry wins this, like...
Oh, no.
He's choking.
Oh, don't.
Oh, he don't.
No.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
It's one-to-one.
All right.
Who do I fight next?
Get in here.
Okay.
Play like your...
That's a nice Aki skin.
I like this one.
I think I like this Aki skin.
Almost.
No, he has to win one more set.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Okay, I didn't...
Oh my god, okay.
That's fine.
Next!
Your turn!
There we go.
my oh nice my turn oh my turn that's right
yeah wait bp lost already oh what how did he lose already that was so fast no that's what i'm saying i'm saying like um Aiton's team is just a lot better.
Like, the teammates they got.
I think it doesn't help that.
Yeah, it's like...
I think it doesn't help.
Okay, what I think Brian's team has, like, the debuff on.
Is that...
Sorry, I'm like...
Okay, is that majority of Brian's teammates are also in the Seijom Slam.
So they have to divide their practice.
that's the only that's the unfortunate thing yeah
like majority of the um everyone like i think like three of the teammates are um three of them are around the 2x ko and i think 2x ko is a lot harder to train for okay bro bro bro bro i'm talking to my chat
chill i was bro chill bro what am i how how do i live how
i don't think i don't think serenity that could do that bro i i said play like her now play like yourself i didn't say play i don't i did not say i said play like her i said play like her bro i don't think 13 knows how to do all that bro i don't you don't know that i don't know this this combo was crazy uh like that's a crazy combo get me Here,
let's see.
I want to see this matchup.
That was a fast brawl pro game.
Hmm.
Okay, Brian F is...
Oh my god, the...
The thing is, I know Fumi...
I think Fumi is the scarier JP player.
She has the most experience, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I know 100% Fumi has the more...
Yeah, I think, I think, I think Fumi is gonna win it.
I don't think, because like Shumi started as a beginner, right?
But Fumi, when we did Seijam Slam, she was already a higher tier.
Yeah.
Isn't Fumi in the second tier?
Wait, she's in second tier then?
Wait, why is she in second tier?
She was like third tier in Seijam Slam.
yeah shouldn't she be in third tier
and i was like i'm confused how she got de-ranked a tier no 100 no item is progressing don't forget to warm up yeah but we still have a time though all right new challenger we still have time i don't want to like do too much um labbing just because like if i do too much um would get like,
I would get like too bad of, like I would get too much bad habits.
That's the thing.
I don't want to get too much bad habits.
Because everyone has like a different play style, you know?
Bro, I thought I was beginner.
You can't, no, you don't understand, I thought I was beginner because I, I even, I even didn't, I even like practice less than I should.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Oh, I was gonna grab that.
What?
I grabbed you first!
Oh my god.
You're not doing this.
To me.
That's right.
Oh, wait.
Oh my gosh.
That's right.
You don't expect that, do you?
No one ever does.
Oh, I did that too late.
Oh.
Oh, no.
He just slowly walked up to me and grabbed me.
That's illegal.
Bro, stop grabbing me.
I don't like that.
What?
That should be mine.
There you go.
No one ever expects this move.
But I'm just one.
I'm not surprised, like I said.
It's going to be the same matchup.
I'm not surprised that that was the matchup.
Oh.
There we go.
Get out of here!
Like I said, like, I know Idom's team was the best player, the best the team.
to be worried about.
That's the thing.
Brian's team just had...
Brian's team just had all...
Majority of them were just at the other...
The 2xKO tournament.
They spent...
They had to learn a new...
A lot of them had to learn a new game, too.
So they had to split practice.
While, like...
I think, like, IDOM's team...
Some of them aren't...
Some of them aren't in the...
So, have the advantage of being able to just practice...
Street Fighter.
There you go.
Oh.
I wanted to butch slam, but I messed it up.
I don't care what I messed it up.
I got to do butch slam.
What?
Oh, I didn't press the thingy.
I hate it when they do the grab.
It's not cool.
It'll be a shame if I...
The start!
Oh
That's right my turn that's right my turn
Oh, no, oh no not my turn anymore What oh my god, yo bro.
I'm I'm not getting over there bro what oh What oh that was smart
What did I do?
Oh wait
Guys, I bet you I'm gonna do that.
I'm gonna do that in the Seretina matchup again.
Oh my god, it took one mistake.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, get me out of this hellhole.
Get me out of here.
At least I'm not in the corner, guys.
That's fine.
Oh wait, I wasn't supposed to...
Okay, whatever.
I'm supposed to do another...
I'll try and do that.
There we go.
Oh, I did it too early.
That's right.
That's right, nobody ever expects that!
For some reason!
I don't know why.
But I'll take those.
Oh my god, I got in the corner.
Boom!
No, I know I was gonna fight that team.
Like I said, I'm not surprised at all.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, no.
Not the grab.
That's it, that's it, that's it, that's it!
That's it!
It's fine, I'm not in the corner.
I take those.
It's fine, I take those.
I got out of the corner.
Yeah, I know.
They're going to have a time to...
They would tell me.
They would tell me whenever it's my turn.
What?
You know, see, I'm starting to get tired now, too, from labbing.
So, I think this would be the last one.
That's why I didn't want to lab too much.
Like I said, I can tell when I...
When I started to get tired.
There we go.
Get... Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
No, not the punish.
No!
Oh, I thought I'd get it first.
All right.
Oh, wait, I definitely forgot about that good thing.
All right, we're going to stop allowing me now.
I'm tired.
I feel myself getting tired.
All right, we'll watch a game.
We'll watch a game.
All right, we'll watch.
Who do we watch?
We'll watch this game.
Or you guys will watch this game.
Yeah, I'm drinking my nursing my coffee now Hmm
Oh my god dragon boss e
Lab for four minutes at least I think it was enough laving I think we did enough
Yeah, Terry
I'm so relaxed
no commentary here's the iPad children you know if he if he starts to like if I'm jumping to dodge his oh my god that's scary I was like who are these voices in my I forgot I forgot what my teammates sounded like I was like yeah is there voice chat and street fighter who's talking
what do you recommend I had teammates there first thing I do in round one then do you think rushing him in the or fireballing I think the voices and then just you can like wait for him to do a headbutt um if you think you can't stop it and then start your pressure because you just take your turn back out here and do like crouch me and punch in right and then uh is diying a slow headbutt
you actually get it okay oh no yeah the meds are fading i'm eefy now guys this is so long i hadoki how you doing you're waiting now i got my caramel latte but i don't it's not looking good for me you're ready to go we're gonna lean on you a lot no no no i'm just 10 points guys I'm just a 10 pointer.
We could switch that.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
It won't be as exciting to watch.
We all want to watch Feisty play.
Three rounds.
Oh, God, stop.
Nobody wants to see that.
Not even me.
It's okay, I believe.
We all want to see it.
Oh, God, man.
I just joined Parky's training and dropped it.
Why not?
Yeah, you could do that.
No, me and Kirkure are buddies.
He asked me to teach him TFT.
Guys, no, don't me.
Guys, I cannot be around three, guys.
Don't do this to me.
I'm too EP, guys.
I remember he was just asking a question on the bus.
Yeah.
He just, that team didn't even really care about Street Fighter, just kept asking me a question about TFT.
It was funny.
Look at Idom on Honda right now.
They were definitely practicing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure.
But it's okay.
We got this.
So I can't wait for my hot pot, guys.
So I'm thinking about the hot pot.
Yeah.
Round two.
Fight.
Too.
you said
he was waking up headbutt uh like wake up ex headbutt he was waking up ex headbutt yeah okay you grabbed a lot of them yeah it has armor so like it'll beat your button but if you grab it like your grapple wins he also drive reversal once um so if you want to try beating both of you just walk back the knockdown and just got he's not working yeah guys i Guys,
I think the coffee was a really bad idea.
Guys, the coffee was a bad idea.
Guys, the eyes are getting heavy.
It's basically like, because it has armor, so it comes like...
Wash my face.
Okay, I'm going to wash my face a little.
Guys, my eyes are getting tired.
Grab the EX head, bud.
I'm going to go wash my face real quick, guys.
Okay.
All
right.
So is it a bad idea, you think, then, to, like, if I get the notch down to wake up Meady?
You can do it sometimes, but, like, maybe.
How long has Teary been fighting for it?
Grabber.
Okay.
How long did he be fighting for?
Oh, no.
I've just been casually sipping it.
Oh, my God.
How many rounds do I have?
This guy's on a 10-game win streak.
Who will defeat the Terry?
Guys, this...
Terry has been on a 10-game win streak.
Alright, guys.
We gotta move on to the next player after this.
Alright.
Terry, stay in.
Ooh, someone challenged.
Someone break Terry's win streak.
Wait, I think the vice is gonna beat it.
Guys, I think, like, for this bracket, I'm gonna stop commentating.
I'm actually getting tired.
I didn't think it would be this long I really didn't think I need to save my energy for my bracket
why am I match for wait what wait I thought I'm I'm second wait why am I match for yeah you're last nice you can warm up i said but i said second please you got this oh it's okay it's the same thing don't worry there's a realistic chance it's like you play last and then you'll play immediately right after again oh my god stop it yeah yeah yeah all right it's time time to end this tournament as much as i know you guys want to stick around for a few more hours we got it Now I'm getting hot pot after this.
It's been great.
Alright.
Alright, alright.
Alright, alright, alright, alright, alright.
We're gonna go look for invites, I assume.
Yeah, we got our invite.
Why am I last again?
This is not fair.
It's actually not fair.
Wait, they already started playing?
Nice.
When did they start?
I wasn't even in the lobby.
All
right.
You just block until your drive gates.
Yeah, no one told me that we started.
no one waited for me i'm so sad now observe
oh nice nice okay okay nice
guys i might not do a lot of commentary for this i need to save my energy i'm actually running i'm running with 15 percent battery right now.
Oh my god.
No, observe.
No, watch this.
Here.
No, observe.
Watch this.
Here.
No, observe.
Receive your friend request.
No, observe this.
NPC.
Here.
Oh, now.
Observe this.
Here.
Watch this now, here, watch this, observe, here, now, observe, here, now.
You can do button drivers when you're close.
I hate JV so much.
We're losing here at a JP ASMR.
This gives me more energy when I do the MP.
Bro, what if I just do JP ASMR?
all right i just say jp lines no here observe this here observe this no now watch this yes no observe this you're closing you can level tooth or something this is my mpc stream
does parry
nice whoa Whoa!
Okay, Emily, looking good, looking good.
Yay!
Whoa.
No, observe this.
Wow, now you...
Oh, that's new.
That's new.
He started laughing.
I've never seen that before.
I was like, wait a minute, I've never heard that lie.
Now, observe this.
No, now.
Observe this.
Now, no.
Here.
I was like, that laugh was new.
JP laughs?
I know.
I was like, what?
I've never seen this before.
Here.
No.
Observe this.
Here.
No.
Now.
Observe this.
Here.
God, please.
We should really have a day where we ban JP.
new sound
jesus bro well if she's in the corner especially she's gonna teleport through the portal to try and get out
yeah that was a crazy grab that was a good mix up i will admit that what the did you hear me at capcom Fan JP for a day and you'll see an increase of player base.
Do you like money?
We like money here.
Well, here.
Whoa.
Now, honestly, if they...
I hope they see it and they're like, wait, we can make so much money if we just do like character bands every week or so.
Oh, it's like the Overwatch thing.
Remember in Overwatch?
Overwatch, they did like hero bans where like you're not allowed to play certain character.
Jesus, what am I?
Where they basically like did the thing where you can't play a certain character for rank and stuff.
We should do that.
Oh, goodbye.
Just careful of those command grabs up close.
And when you're in mid-range, you can just chill a bit and look for buttons to drive us or charge up fireballs.
How would they explain JP's removal?
He's old!
That's how you can explain it.
Bro, he's old.
He's got to take his medication or some shit.
Do you want some fireballs?
I think he would grab his back.
Dodge this.
Bro, what am I watching?
No!
Watch this!
Now!
Like...
Now I understand why people are depressed.
I have to play this character in Rink all the time.
Now I know.
Now I know why people in Street Fighter.
Bro!
Okay.
Now observe.
Here.
I...
Nice.
Good patience.
Oh, that was insane prediction.
That really was insane prediction there.
No, I'm watching this is...
I'm depressed watching this JP.
Watching JP in general is depressing.
It's, I'll say, it's not even fun to watch.
I wish it was fun to watch, but it's not.
Like, how do you counter that?
You don't have draft.
It feels like there's nothing you can do.
Like, how?
How do you have fun?
How is this fun?
I don't find this fun to watch.
I'm sorry.
I don't find this fun to watch at all.
It is absolutely not fun to watch.
I'm like tilted watching this as someone that's not even playing.
That's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Now observe.
Like, even if I have have a JP on my team.
I don't think this is fun though.
I would be like, I hate you.
You're on my team and I hate you.
I feel sorry for Emily that she has to play against this.
Bro.
I thank God there's no JP in your level.
Thank God.
Like, you have to be, like, 24-7 active.
Let me try.
NT.
Nice try.
That was good.
And you just, like, you'll win next time.
Yeah, it's just, like, you'll win next time.
Yeah, it's just anytime you get close to your command grab and it puts you full screen.
So if you can jump them, then you'll win for sure.
Yeah, absolutely interfering.
Yeah, it's just that block.
All right.
I ain't about that.
it i ain't about that
hello hello hi oh cool time my discord was broken oh that's unfortunate oh you could have exited exited what the game like after the first game like if something's wrong you should you should stop the match oh i didn't know that you must have been like why is my coach not coaching me yeah i was like why isn't my coach saying anything like hello but then i have to manager close it and reopen it so yeah but mine broke as well mine broke as well today and it froze my stream oh really yeah wait carcute gained 100 mr since we last played that's not good yeah that's might not be as good gotta do this come on i'm number one round one
come here
bro i could have done that
damn whoa oh that's good
oh nice oh that's that's a good come back let's see it's shaping no coaching can fix this
Let's go, Justin.
I jinxed him.
Let's not go!
I take it back!
I'm sorry!
Yeah.
I wouldn't jump at him.
Let's go, Karku!
Let's go!
Let's focus on that.
Let's go, Karku!
I reversed jinxed it.
This is your thought, Toki.
I said
yes, I would was funny.
I didn't realize it's not being funny.
What have you done?
I think that was funny.
Oh no, that's not good.
Oh.
Oh, that was clutch.
Oh my god, you're the GOAT.
That was so clutch.
Don't be afraid to wake up with super sometimes because you're not really baiting it, I don't think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
See, I told you, I reversed Jinx to chat.
Let me call him back for a sec.
Oh my god.
What?
Where am I?
Whoa.
Yo!
Let's go, Karaku.
I'm doing it, I'm jinxing him.
See, oh, um...
Punish?
Nice.
No perfect here.
Oh no.
Not this row.
What the heck is that move?
That's like, yeah.
What is that?
I would just drive rush cross me and punch the eye.
You know how like the coach is like, I would do this and this.
I saw it when he was like, do speed dash and I was like, what the?
Got him.
All right.
Nice.
Let's go.
All right.
Yay.
That means I can lose my game.
All right.
best in your hands.
I'm good for 10.
Oh, is that move not available in modern?
I was like, what is that?
Not only my coach nephew, but my other side coach in the chat, automatic.
That guy also taught me a lot about being fired.
Oh, my God.
I'll get my water in.
No, it's first to 70.
Remember, you can stand up and pick him a lot.
70.
and you probably can still jump at him and i probably can still drive rush in your life yeah yeah i think so and that's why i'm like show maxing i was like whatever happens i'm heading to i'm clocking out whatever happens is clock out out hours
yeah less commentary from me right now just because like i'm conserving energy i'm like I didn't do that.
Whoa!
Oh!
Wait, that's crazy!
That's a crazy move.
Whoa!
Yeah, she's cooking.
Damn, Faisy is insane at this game.
Wow.
I don't think everyone else... I know, like, the Aki can do parries, but...
we're not here for that
that's why she's the 20 point exactly that's crazy she has to win two more sets that's the hard part about being a 20 pointer wow
oh my god oh and she forgot the that thing goes what am i what what is going on what
oh that fake out that's crazy that's such a good fake out yeah i think mostly drivers because i think he's looking hard for that area yeah
okay nope he's adapting is this illegal
bro this is legal how dare she adapt to my my teammate give us a Japan trip that's
good once his name skitso BM I'm sorry okay Japanese curry I was like what is that group let's go Japanese curry
I think from farther away you can probably jump.
That's the...
I was like, what is that name?
Okay.
Oh my god, what a read!
That's crazy.
That's a crazy read.
Fuck, I should have done the dash back.
Oh, that's fine.
Well, get off of it.
Nice.
You're doing insane.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's go Japanese curry.
I told you this reverse jinx works, guys.
Whoopsies.
I proclaim oopsies.
Yeah, but I'm doing the jinx.
doing the fgc jinx guys now they're like let's go justin and then he gets his absolute kicked in we're doing the let's go curry we're trying to jinx
what oh my god oh my god oh my god i'm trying my don't be yeah i know that's fine he's not gonna get level three now this around probably
Oh, he did not get off of her.
How dare he?
Oh no.
Oh, combo time.
Oh, no, get off of her.
Oh my god!
Oh, that's crazy!
You see, this is why you're the 20-pointer, not me.
This is why you're the 20-pointer.
Oh my god.
That was so good.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Now I'm sorry.
Thank you.
This is my turn.
Okay.
I will admit guys, I am getting EP.
They are too.
It's a battle of attrition at this point.
More like who wants it.
I'm a bit EP guys.
I don't know about wanting.
You got this.
Please.
You're good.
Your butt slender are doing really good.
And your auto heavies up close.
Yep.
Shake it out.
I'm going to stand up, actually.
I've been sitting for way too long.
Why is she not joining?
Are we waiting?
She's literally asleep in the chair.
I was like, what are we waiting for right now?
Wait, Dan, you wake up early, right?
What time did you wake up?
Yeah.
Like, my son wakes up at 6 a.m.
every day.
Oh, okay, no, me too.
I mean, not my son, but like, I don't have a secret son out there.
I see.
She got a son with a...
You rent those, too?
Yeah, that's how I rent a son.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, the grab.
Wait, she knows.
Oh,
no.
Wait, she downloaded me.
Unless.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I want to do that charge for the headbutt.
And, like, sometimes you can do EX headbutt when you're getting pressured.
Yeah.
There you go.
Oh.
Only when you're getting pressure though, you don't want to do it on screen.
Whoops.
I know you just said that, but.
That's fine.
I'll play a lot slower.
Yeah.
Yeah, when you have the life fleet, you can just sit back, hold your charge and head, but...
Oh.
Nice punish.
Nice.
Oh.
That's fine.
That's like no damage.
I like that.
Oh, I knew she was going to grab too.
If she gets close, you can do your L3 super.
You can also just hold charge and try and butt slam.
Oh, I knew she.
Oh, that's fine.
If she goes ahead, you can hit that button.
Oh, nice.
She's making you play more passive.
I don't like it.
Yeah, just if you have the life bleed, you can play super passive.
Wait, what's that?
You want more life than her?
Yeah.
Nice.
Now just make sure you don't get jumped in on.
If she jumps at you, you headbutt.
Okay.
Because you have such a big life bleed, you don't need to really worry about anything.
What?
Oh.
Okay, not anymore.
Well, you still got it.
He was like, weird.
I mean, like, do a grab on that.
I'm sure.
Yeah, just make sure not to do the EX head, but unless, like, she's really close to you.
This?
Oh.
I want to do the grab.
Unlucky.
Nice.
Can I just hold your charge?
Oh!
I got you again.
Hold your charge and you can EX head by if she gets close.
Okay.
there you go nice nice nice dude you're cooking okay she's making me play so slow i don't like it i hate playing slow no but if you play slow you can win i know but i'm so bad with i'm like really bad with slow gameplay that's
my one weakness and she knows because i have to do that for
Yeah, have your finger on the L3 button and just press it if she gets close.
Nice.
Stop playing so slow!
Nice timing.
Oh.
She always does that too.
I need to like be aware.
Oh.
What?
Okay.
Hmm.
Nice.
Just try and land your auto heavy somewhere else.
Oh, I heard auto heavy.
Yeah, that was a good try.
Yeah, you had to go for it, I think.
It's okay.
You have all your meter for this round, so if you land a big hit, it'll do a lot.
Oh.
Stop.
Like that shot?
Okay.
And then just hold back and if she jumps or does anything you can hide but...
Do I need a special head player?
Yeah, the regular one.
Not a special head.
Okay, that works for me.
I'll just sit there.
Oh, what?
Oh!
Yeah, make sure you're not holding down.
Okay.
Okay, you just need one more.
if you could just charge for butt slam that'd be good okay oh wait that's i didn't want to do that that was an accident but i didn't yeah it's fine i don't care let's go i did it it doesn't matter all right that was great okay god she made me adapt i hate that that's so stupid yeah that's the worst part that's the worst part i said
Just play how you usually play and we'll do rock, paper, scissors.
Guys, I hate adapting.
Guys, I have to think.
I'm the EP too.
We're at 40, yeah.
I'm also EP.
They have 10.
Dude, dude.
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna do this.
double points it's just you've got to jump the command grabs that's the only thing yeah jump the command they need to make it a different color it's not my fault the sound cue where he goes away you have to like instinctively press up in that situation if he just says away yeah all right that can be you don't even have to react literally just hold up when you see him do that specific button i'll stay in the spectate every time off of it i'm gonna relax a bit now oh uh doke you're gonna be playing immediately wait what yeah they have you playing that's not fair i demand um second they're having you play again it's all good bro
no time to relax i mean honestly i mean you could go into training mode just have jp do it like 15 times you'll never like not hear no no neffy already did it to me like a hundred times oh yeah just you could try you could like just not react and just hold up when you're getting in oh my bro i just wanted to chill you're doing great you're doing great yeah one minute at a time don't worry about anything one minute i think it's just with jp there's like too many things to focus on but like i guess i'll prioritize the command grab else like you're doing good at blocking every bullshit that he does like you're you're fine wait did you ever take the risk and just like jump over the double portals in the air or no not really oh i i can't because we're on the away side i have to be on the right for fair for fairness apparently but maybe like when you do because when you see the double portals i see you do like dry rush just relax what is that button medium kick yeah or heavy kick you could
do like drive rush throw can she do that yeah you could do that yeah i think i need to drive us throw more is what i was thinking too yeah like when instead of because she's not really like trying to attack at that point she's just waiting for you to to do your heavy kick and then just wait yeah so yeah you should just throw her more okay and then once you like start throwing her she's probably gonna start doing the the counter thing the amnesia where she sounds like a ghost of herself so like if you land a couple throws just mind she's gonna start doing that on reaction you guys can start this one or i guess well i'm just waiting i think they're giving her tips right now you know oh yeah they're giving her tips yeah i mean that was that was uh dokey not even holding back for the charge headbutt like they can adapt if you was the was the medium punch button on honda on modern she should do that more she did like that it's just medium Yeah.
But did you feel sure about the headbutt into EX headbutt tech?
What?
Yeah, you can do like regular headbutt into the EX headbutt because she always presses medium punch.
So if you do that on block, you can go straight into it.
Also if you're close to her, just keep mashing medium punch.
Oh, like, yeah, like she can't do anything.
Like if you keep just pressing it.
Like auto or no auto?
No auto either.
Oh, okay.
Or is it auto?
Guys, I'm getting overwhelmed right now.
Okay, I think maybe we're overwhelmed here.
Oh, no.
I think what you were doing was good.
You're doing that.
Oh, guys, you overwhelmed me.
I told you.
This is not good.
I'm going on burnout.
I don't care.
Yeah, that's fine.
Nice.
Oh, she always grabs that.
I didn't even remember it.
Yay!
Nice jump.
Yeah!
Great jump.
Okay.
I don't know, we just have to do this.
I know you- oh wait, I grabbed first!
That could grab.
There we go.
That might be dumb.
but i think if you land your auto have you one more time
that's right nobody expects that not even me all right nice nice you're so good at jumping over the fireballs yeah
I'm lucky.
It's fine.
I'll take that.
What would I do next?
Oh, that.
But what would I do after that?
Nice.
Oh, that's not nice.
No, no, nephew, you jinxed me.
Oh, you're good.
There we go.
Oh, unlucky.
I knew she was going to grab, too.
Oh.
I don't have a cutscene.
I do!
I got my cutscene.
Oh, unlucky.
That was so fast.
I was expecting that to be...
so fast oh i'm dead here that's fine she has no meter now
you try to bust them a bit more too but okay yeah but she's blocking it so it's fine if she blocks it's just sometimes it'll hit her by your ball and you're getting in off of it
oh that's that was poor type
Oh, unlucky.
Oh, I'm messing that up.
That's okay.
Nice.
Yeah, just try to keep her here.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Yeah, it's okay.
Yeah, just keep your charge and you can use that whenever she is close.
Oh, I tried.
You have to hold back though.
Oh, I did it again.
Ah!
I don't know how to counter that.
Yeah, I get in there.
Five seconds.
Oh.
Yeah, it's just when you have the light just like literally hold hold back yeah so that you always because you're getting hands instead of the heads up because you don't have enough back charge okay yeah but now you can try and get your auto heavy combos oh
she jumps
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, that's unlucky.
She grabbed it.
That's okay.
Just press your L through anything.
Okay.
Oh, I pressed your L through.
Nice.
Train butsling or jump.
Aw.
I'm gonna try this way.
I try to jump that.
It's just so fast.
Yeah, it's fast.
Hmm.
Uh.
She adapted to me.
Okay.
I think I'm thinking too much, too.
I'm not vibing anymore.
Oh, this try, this try.
Almost.
nice try indeed it's okay you guys just went all of them now i can chill
all right uh yeah i yeah i got overloaded i think i was just it was better i think i got too overloaded
yeah it was just too much information in my head yeah we're gonna try to fire ball again but the thing is he sometimes just jumps in for the fireball so uh i think it's just like what do i do yeah i think yeah i got too much information anymore also i feel like when you're aggressive he just doesn't know what to do they gave so much information at once right before i started yeah he'd just be freaking out uh yeah they went over i said four moves guys four moves was like if it was like um they gave me as i went then it's fine but like the fact that like i had so much information in my head right before i started
yeah oh that's perfectly spaced
yeah i mean 4-1 was pretty good record it was a pretty good record i'm fine with that i'm fine with that record oh wait wait is he yeah i think okay oh okay oh okay yeah i was gonna say why didn't they timed out or the controller timed out okay no i said it's just he didn't block like the third hit
I'm just gonna relax a little I need to go back to vibing I need to go back to vibing so what did they do in the same sense uh he might have to restart his game or something yeah I restarted my game and it worked
I'm happy I won 4-1 was a good record yeah I was like I'm happy I did my fight there
and now I'm just testing all my buttons um 40 20 i think that's the score maybe just kill him oh yeah we started it yeah i think if i have to play another one um if i have to play another one uh i'm just gonna go back to my old strat yeah
because like um i just got too overloaded i was like i overthinking is like oh what do i do i do i'm happy i'm happy i'm happy with uh with being able to do it i have to do what i did okay yeah because like it worked and then they're like do this more and i was like well we both but my strat was working yeah i was just like they're like you should you should do this and then this and then this i was like but i was winning
I was like, was that not winning?
Yeah.
It was good advice, but my mind doesn't do well with that.
That's why I like it when people talk about random things, because, like, my mind doesn't overthink.
I mean, you guys are cool with it just being a restart, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, you're like, yeah, we should.
Yeah, I get my mental is like, I always like, if I get too overloaded, my mental.
kill his day all over the place but like i did my i think i'm still happy with how i did yeah he basically didn't do anything yeah i'm joking i'm joking guys yeah yeah already starting i thought i thought they had to reset so i was chilling
don't expect me to be a pushover round one there's a lot of buns on my um dry brush Yeah, he does this.
Did he disconnect again?
Because as soon as he jittered and then...
What?
Okay.
As soon as he jittered and stopped doing stuff.
Do we have to reset the game again?
Like, what happens if he can't play?
Like, that would really fucking suck if they had to forfeit.
Yeah.
But it's like...
I think he's just reset his game because he didn't restart his game last time.
Yeah, I mean, he might be having issues with his PC and his game, so he might just reset.
I had to restart Street Fighter twice today, so...
The thing is, I don't know how long...
Street Fighter.
I'm just thinking, like, how long's the intermission?
Like, at some point we can't wait forever, I'm sorry.
I'm too tired.
I don't think I can last another...
two hours.
Yeah, same.
I'm also
pretty tired.
I'm using up all my juice.
I'm using all my juice.
I ended this series.
I drank coffee before we started the finals.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
I'm back starting to hurt.
I'm old.
Oh no.
I don't even know what's hurting anymore.
It's something.
I just don't know what.
This event is sabotaging the BJs.
Oh, I think I'm the last one.
Oh, no.
Actually, it's me and Fumi.
Kirk, you said he can forfeit the first round.
That sucks.
I don't know.
But I think it's like the production.
I don't think we can make that call.
It's like the ad music section.
Yeah, I was going to say the production makes the final call.
Yeah.
Going by, oh wait, it's 10 p.m.
Never mind.
If he's East Coast, I don't think he can get a controller.
10 p.m.
I don't think he can get a controller.
It's 1.22 for me.
Yeah, I feel like we should have started earlier.
Yeah, I think so.
I feel like this should have just been two days.
I think so, too.
The final should be on another day.
Yeah.
I think he couldn't because of the slam.
Oh, yeah, true.
it will also be like monday wait no it'll be sunday but uh
it needs to update the firmware did like they just pushed out a new update in between this game
uh that's crazy they're like a controller update okay well i will say i have some sympathy for it because i was having a couple of controller issues at twitch con uh and so i definitely have felt some of what he's talking about before
i think everyone's tired all the east coast people are mega tired bro he's at one hot pot
some of his buns are being held like uh red like they're held down i've had that before um as well so like i definitely know exactly what he's talking about i i know i don't know how to fix it, though.
At TwitchCon, what happened was, uh, it was not, it was not my mediums.
It was my directional keys.
I was, like, randomly holding jump at times.
And there was, like, times where I was, like, practicing with the rules, and on the PCs, I was, like, I let go of my control, and I was, like, jumping up for, I don't know, for no reason.
But do you also have the same controller?
Yeah.
Uh, we, uh, we all got, like, the same controller for the last Sage Amsamba that me and Karki played in.
because we got one we we got prizes for going top two I
actually have that controller too I'm happy I'm not using it right now it's a pretty sick controller it definitely has some weird things though
sorry I was zoning out guys I'm I'm zoning out guys just getting there it's just I'm just, let's see.
It's...
It's getting there.
Oh!
Apparently, it's not working for him.
Do you think he has to use, like, an Xbox controller?
I feel like there's no way he knows how to play on an Xbox controller.
Yeah.
I don't know if you'll have a backup.
Okay.
Oh, God.
I'm trying to stay locked in.
So rabbit tapping.
Pick PNG.
TikTok.
Wish I could post that picture in the group server without it being toxic.
Have you used your keyboard?
Oh, my God.
You're calling out.
You're losing some guy.
his keyboard i feel like he might he should forfeit at that point i think he's just forfeited he's keyboard yeah but like i think they should give him a i know it's messed up does they give a time limit but like i don't know how long this fix is gonna be if they're gonna drag this out yeah i feel like most games have a have a time limit yeah because it's like 10 minutes or something okay he's gonna reset his computer okay he should have reset his computer the first thing he done we're going to um training mode with me dude can we move on to the next match and then he's going back to this cuz like it's the order that matters though that's this thing it doesn't actually matter for if we move if we delayed this match because 20 points yeah I mean I it adds pressure to the situation yeah i think they want to add the pressure for it right because next match could be the one that decides at all yeah
sorry let me rephrase it will be the match that it serves at all when emily wins
wait guys i'm gonna just associate for a little i'm tired i'm actually really tired now Like all the adrenaline came out of me.
I have to disassociate a little, guys.
I mean, I can't just grab all the time if she jumps so much, right?
What do you mean?
Like, I can't just grab if she jumps like everything.
I'm going to lock off right now.
Like on her knockdown?
Yeah.
Taking a quick attack.
Yeah, but it's mostly when you do your EX fan, I think you can grab her more.
more yeah
but if she jumps you can either meet you her or like do your back heavy or you can walk back don't worry i won't accidentally fall asleep i want i won't accidentally fall asleep guys don't worry i'm just tired now i'm actually your charge i think it's just because like fighting games tweaks too much bring space and when i dream I don't think and I had to think so much and thinking makes me tired like any normal person like thinking makes me so tired no no not off the entire yeah especially in the tournament yeah you're doing it too slow it drains me really hard
yeah wow that felt realistic you did a walk up there time too hungry time to do what i feel like is he back yet i also don't think she's gonna just wake up di anything back in she blocks it every time he's not back why isn't he back guys where did he go Where did he go?
I hope they don't put me in another one.
I just want to hang out.
I don't want to play another one.
Just let me hang out.
Give me the free ride to Japan.
I said he's back.
Oh, he's just challenged.
Got this.
Well, apparently the controller is working now.
Alright.
I watch.
Oh my god.
There's that medium punch that they told me to use that overwhelm.
Roll that lag here.
It's fine.
I'm gonna check him.
Nice.
Stop.
Stop!
Is he scared of you?
Stop.
Sumo spirit.
What the heck is that move?
What are all these moves I've never seen?
Well, I know that move.
Bro, he's doing combos.
They exist for Honda?
That's the thing.
that's crazy honda has combos guys did you know that is that death i'm not sure i can uh x-ray yeah yeah well i because i know he has an anti-farm as well yeah he has really yeah it was yeah it was good waiting there okay what if i just maybe don't ready guys i got we were they said don't start we were waiting for an ad for That game has to count.
That's not for that should count.
That game should count.
That game.
I think.
I think that game should count.
Because I'm Eepy.
It stopped working again.
Okay.
Yeah.
I wrote it.
I hope they don't see that.
No, they gotta de-queue him.
they got it there's just no way this is there's nowhere waiting 30 minutes for him yeah we can't give them no no no yeah i'm not doing that i feel like we we yeah this is insane bro feel like i'm on the twilight zone like what's going on he's he's suggesting the ff as well because i think he feels bad yeah oh oh so he's gonna he's gonna play the second round on a controller okay i used bathroom i'll okay i'm gonna wait till you guys get a game before i use the bathroom all right oh yay first game they said we were the first game to throw in like you didn't win that like i hope so all right all right all right all right all right good luck i go i go p now i
go they were ready i think because the problem is they were they were trying to get it on made broadcast and then and then like apparently like kakarki just joined right so we just started playing and then uh but they were like playing ads they're doing like a five minute ad segment or something also my pride vice has gotten cold and i'm sad
guys i definitely made a mistake drinking coffee on an empty stomach tell me not feel so good now
tell me not feel good i'm gonna see if i can grab something that he give me a sec yeah tell me hurt now i need something in my i can't i want to he's playing a ps4 controller so order it i lose the guys this is really embarrassing i have like i have i think he can't I bought at the cafe.
Don't worry about it.
So I go, I go grab a cheesecake in my stomach.
Okay.
You know, I feel sad.
Oh
no!
Playing really well on PlayStation controller, not gonna lie.
Let's go!
i think he's good yeah it's not i think so i'm sorry it took way too long let's go
all right but we have to play another set would it as fast as i could oh wait oh wait wait wait wait what no we're done we both instinctively oh okay and we both actually press it by accident so yeah the they're gonna be so confused no no we we both just instinctively press yeah request again that's both of our problems oh my god you're so good man i'm about to score the legendary six perfect rounds in one versus two
yeah fight back why are you punching yourself is it would it be messed up if we put karku like first too like oh yeah wait that's a dream yeah no we i feel like we should like it ends it fast if we if we get it we'll end it faster i like i like where your head's at yeah i'm sorry i it might not be like very sportsman like but also it's been almost seven hours yeah i'm sorry i agree okay guys i'm sorry you got this emily i'm on the wrong side oops what you just gotta jump the command grab uh i think you gotta leave it whatever you did also they sent me in first too so i i at that point that is true yeah at that point i don't care anymore
okay my discord's working yeah coach so we have 50 points right now yeah we have 50.
Yeah, we're at 50 points.
Okay.
We're at 50.
We just need to win either two regular games or one.
Or I mean.
Oh.
That's fine.
Guys, we'll be messed up if I walk out a little bit.
Because I want to walk.
I just want to get up right now.
I really want to just stand up and walk around.
My apartment Yeah, okay.
All right, you guys I believe in you guys you can cheer them.
Let's go foo me I'm jinxing.
Let's go foo me
It's very
Oh, no, no, no, no, no Wait, I think I went What's Oh my god, how did that work?
That goes through my fireball?
Yeah, your regular one.
Oh my god, I TP'd.
Fine.
Try.
Oh.
Just be patient.
Nice.
Over the ice firewall here and throw her.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I missed my grab.
Yeah, I meant like the regular one, not the charge one.
Oh my god.
Into just drawn.
Well.
Here.
Oh.
I
come back to
more bullshit bro i wish i'm sorry but i wish i missed this entire matchup let's go fumi let's go
yeah i i come back and i have to keep watching this oh my god
oh my god thank god don't ask
Let's go, Fumi!
Let's go!
The jinx.
I'll keep doing it.
Maybe it'll work again.
Come on!
Nice.
You can keep doing your jumps, guys.
how come i can't dp i don't get it no here observe now observe here no no now observe here now observe here oh
okay i'm late super winnable just you got it one run at a time yeah you can go for dry brush combos if you're not confident in that one
here now observe here now observe here go Go now.
Yes.
Observe.
Here.
Now.
Now observe.
Here.
Now go.
Observe.
Oh,
I don't have light.
It's okay.
Move.
Now observe.
Here.
Move.
Now observe.
Observe.
Here.
Oh my god.
Oh, I hate watching this the most.
Not here.
Now observe.
Here.
Oh.
I do
think Bumi should be in tier 3.
Not tier 2.
Just because, like, the Seijam Slamshoot was tier 3.
So it wouldn't make sense to drop her a tier.
I guess you could say, oh, she hasn't played in a while too.
But isn't she...
primarily an fgc streamer or is that someone else
yeah she's really good i remember in stat slam she was like the scariest player in her and she was the scariest player in tier three yeah uh she more variety streamer i guess that's why so it's like how i haven't played slam uh tree fighter since um let me try wait can you actually treasure fan there that's not a guaranteed but i don't think she jumped i remember it when i was in the slam she was a scary player uh yeah nice try good try that was just very tilting to fight against you're basically at the doorstep of beating her though it's like one yeah i would say she's like hard to interaction hard to um i'm like the first two games are actually one disruptor yeah all
right here we go so it's 50 40.
yeah it's not fun to watch jp play i don't care who's playing jp like i remember like the other team was also playing one of the teams we first we're playing jp it was not fun to watch i was so tired of watching jp's fighting all right remember the jump yeah forcing emily to face jp is toxic therefore carcass should play match oh yeah never mind I wouldn't say that.
That's so true, though.
I certainly don't want to watch because I'm scared.
I'm, like, nervous for my team.
Okay, let's go, Curry.
Guys, I'm so scared to watch.
I know it takes a lot of skill to...
It takes a lot of skill also to play JP like I mean, I've looked at it I was like I'm I'm I feel tired trying to play it too Oh, oh that was close that's scary
This is very scary to watch
Oh guys, I'm scared now
Oh no, no.
I just wanted to hang out.
Yeah, so he's setting in for all players now.
I think that's the hard part.
Like, everyone is just tired.
And, like, it doesn't help that we weighed it.
it was quick that we got in finals.
I think the cons was that we all waited.
But this team had warmed up with another team.
But we literally had to wait for so long.
Yeah, we ain't warmed anymore.
God, I'm just getting thrown, man.
That's okay.
Oh, no.
Yeah, I don't have to do.
Believe, guys.
We believe.
Like, oh my god.
I'm sad.
I'm going to have to actually play it.
And I'm like...
I'm too...
Ugh.
This is my time to die.
Fuck!
I really don't want to play.
That's the thing.
Alright.
I don't think any of us wanted to keep playing, too.
that's the yeah i have to play i believe though i believe we don't have to play we don't have to play i believe i believe the
thing is i don't know if kimberly uh feisty would be better or yeah you got the buff you're good i don't know like feisty would be better should i be better for a second i
just don't want to be the last game i don't i i'd rather be the second game than the game right i
guess i know i'm just fully slouched right now this is so scary oh my gosh
this is so scary
no my wait oh my god oh my god that's crazy mine lock in lock in you got this i try to do level I'm not gonna watch I'm not gonna watch this is way too scary as I'm not gonna watch 30 I'm turning around I did all reversal literally turn I care to turn around but I I'm too fucking stressed though I don't even care about this thing I'm like way too stressed out right now I it's been a very stressful week i'm not even gonna watch right now i'm making keep getting my jokes Washing this
Okay, I look for quick
Is this a more stressful event?
They'll do Oh my god, guys, I don't want them Long okay I'm way my heart like my Blood pressure might not be good right now I'm My blood pressure is definitely not okay right now.
He's buffed.
Careful after you knock him down, he'll probably do something.
Does he get anything?
I don't think so.
Okay.
I think he did.
Oh.
Oh, let me try.
I thought you meant like a normal medium.
Yeah.
oh i don't know no i saw it's fine we put we make car q go first okay i go second i call second yeah okay wait actually no i go third third wait i just realized the points i go third i don't know definitely car q first right yeah definitely car q first what if he's with his controller he's he's checking
i don't want to be last game i mean it's not gonna get to the last game because yeah no matter what 50 50 so uh at most it can't go to the fourth year so whoever we want to sit out for the fourth will we play i think emily definitely sits out i don't want to play her again okay i don't know if that's the thing i don't know if i can beat sir tina like you have you have before you just have to make some small adjustments yeah but she make it i got super overloaded when i had all the information right before we started the first thing is uh do you know how to like stop or jump in because she jumps she just like realized you can't stop a jump so if you if you can stop a jump then she jumps right at me i can't i like i just press circle but like i don't know if i can't react it in time i mean if you want we can have car queue first and then second you i don't know it's either me or you like yeah i like maybe you should go because if you lose it's okay but if you win is over i don't know uh
i guess okay i'll go second as if i lose whatever nephew thinks yeah if i lose then i think that that makes sense then like we go into kimberly right yeah oh damn i don't want to that's tough i
think it's better to have feisty on the versus three yeah whatever three i i'm so locked out guys i the jimmy didn't think i have to play same i did not want to be playing this bro i'm not like i think drinking coffee on an empty stomach was a very bad idea no i understand i i didn't i basically also did the same thing
on we have this and most importantly you guys can trust in me i yeah i trust you some i trust in you and by that i mean let's uh let's hope that car queue hasn't magically learned how to play on a ps4 controller but what are the scores right now um 50 50.
this is way too close i don't like it yeah yeah and uh most importantly it's just important to stay positive always yeah yeah we we drop a combo you miss something but it's like don't let the frustration uh and despair get to you so what do i do when they jump when she jumps at me do i just like circle
uh if you don't have charge you can do circle otherwise you do your headbutt okay you can also try to ear to ear her like just jump with her and yeah i try to jump over She does the charge up for it, so it's super fast.
Yeah, or you can do your EX headbutt if you have a lot of meter.
So like, that's the easiest.
But just make sure you're always holding back or down back and then make sure you let go of down.
I'm starting.
Yeah, we watch.
Two most spirit.
I forgot I wasn't muted.
oh my god oh please i hope i didn't mess up the vibe oh no that's my fault there was like sumo spirit i realized i was no why did i do that yep
oh no i
don't think he's on a playstation controller anymore
I don't know.
He's doing better.
Unless he was, like, practicing.
He might have just been practicing while we were, like, playing our 200 games, you know?
Like, he knew he was going to be picked next.
Yeah, I think he was practicing it.
Most likely.
Did he adapt that fast?
I don't know.
Oh, crap.
Oh, I don't know.
i think he's heading to double di oh my bad is he on it guys do you know he's on his controller especially yeah yeah he's on like ps5 or not okay but remember crouch medium punch into jinn right after you block yeah yeah he's he's feeding a lot of like i i drive rush heavy and he's pressing a button is that is that fake isn't it like am i pressing uh i think you're pressing oh if you press crouch medium punch i think it should be oh so he's not he's he's not on his ps4 controller anymore apparently okay copy
that makes sense i was gonna say like how did he like i was like there's no way he learned the ps4 that fast uh i'm waiting also
like is it possible to swap slots if we have to I mean, I think it's the same thing either way.
I see second.
Yeah.
It's the same thing either way.
Okay.
Wait, how is the same thing either way?
Unless Frodo wins.
And Frodo loses, they both are doing.
I just, I don't know.
I don't think I can do well with that pressure.
That's the thing.
I don't like being like the final call.
So...
I'd rather for, if we can, just be like, oh.
Like, I'm actually, like, not feeling great right now.
My, like, my stress level is so high.
I'll
try, guys.
I'll try.
Keep the genera pressure up.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Okay, guys, I'm sorry.
Nice try.
It's okay.
Yeah, this controller back.
Okay, yeah.
I mean, my bad.
It's all good.
You got this.
Okay.
I guess it's my turn.
Yeah, you got this, don't you?
I was so warmed down.
Oh, what?
Oh, wait.
Oh, we're waiting.
Okay.
Why he grabs that.
Alright, Doki, let's get it.
Oh, my god.
What?
I've never seen those moves before.
Okay.
Nice.
Disney had a few hits.
Oh.
Uh.
That's right, that's right.
That's close.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think you can probably do more normal headbutts too.
Oh, predictable.
She's right.
Nice.
I'm just gonna use it.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
Hold on.
There was.
Hold on, I thought that was.
Nice.
Nice job.
That's your donkey.
Oh my god.
Nice job, nice job.
Okay.
Oh,
that's unlucky timing by me.
Nice.
Let's go.
Oh my god, nice.
Oh, I knew she was going to do that grab too.
Let's go.
I can land at one more time, you win.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Ah, choice does that grab see.
Oh.
No worries, no worries.
Yep.
That's fine.
Oh, I was trying to do the the X went.
Oh no.
It's okay.
If you can land your auto combo, it's kind of low.
Oh, this is bad though.
We're both, I'm burnt out though.
It's very risky.
No, you're going to get yours back soon.
You can wait for yours to come back if you want.
Oh, no!
Oh!
Nice try, nice try.
NT guys.
Very, very close.
Yeah.
I think you got this.
Give us.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Nice.
Big start.
Okay.
Just me, I heard you can.
You're here.
try doing just di's more in neutral because i think she's not gonna stop it going and also wait okay oh um that's fine as long as she doesn't die back oh what oh my controller she does that i'm so sad because my controller didn't work there
oh my light controller actually stopped working I don't want to use it.
Save it, save it, save it.
Yeah, save it.
Oh, that sucks.
That round, my controller's not working.
Oh, he's...
Okay.
Black eye?
Nice.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Nice.
Let's go.
We did it.
Good luck.
I'm leaving.
I'll be back.
That's crazy.
I mean, I'm leaving.
All right.
I mean.
Oh my God.
Leaving it all up to me so bad.
No, no.
You 100% got it.
No, it's not.
It's not.
It's actually the only fitting thing.
I think you're right here.
I think when he's growing.
be right back show him more but when he gets knocked out he matches something a lot okay so like when you do like a button dry rush like you can grab him i think okay yep a positive you got this yeah you got three games to adapt yep yeah
also the ex cycle crusher is plus one in burnout when you're in burnout and the regular kickstarter are zero so like don't match on the ex like on the ex one you just have to hold it or see you guys on the ex like cycle crusher okay
oh wait you guys are on different sides on the wrong side yeah just i just wait what yeah i think you just you're supposed to be technically player one oh i think they're because their overlay is wrong that's why so just just kill them just kill them okay
Hold on guys, I'm double perfecting him.
Well that was nice.
That's a good start.
I did that two rounds ago.
It was good.
Nice.
Thank god.
I forgot about spectating.
Nice.
If he goes over, like when you do double moves, there's sometimes don't press a clutch every punch and you can punish him if he goes on the other side.
Okay.
No, close.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna stop watching.
I'm tired of me.
I'm just tired.
Just keep running off of him because he keeps jabbing.
Oh my god.
Amazing.
This game is amazing.
Oh, I'm dead.
On defense, you have to jump out or back dive sometimes.
I think you're just taking the throw too much for driver recently.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
oh my god
nice you can still summon
nice all right get him to the corner just watch the driver so he's still doing a lot watch watch out for the drive reversals in the corner when you have him there oh my god he's checking everything i gotta stop i'm
back but i'm also not back guys i'm not okay go okay i'll come i'll come back i'll come here and back
oh my god i'm too tired i think tough on you as a driver so yeah but Oh, I thought it was too far.
I didn't think it was going to hit it.
What?
I'm just so scared of doing anything on Waco.
Nice.
You can try and look for whip when this is.
I feel like you whip the scissor kick sometimes.
OK.
Oh my god, bro.
No,
that was too far.
Oh, should have just the item.
I'm too tired, man.
Like, I just...
Nice and nice.
You can try drive rushing after you run off of him and he blocks as he always backdashes.
Okay, you're right.
Nice.
Hit level one.
That's fine.
And I think if you drive rush, do cross the leg punch, because sometimes that scissor kicks are going over it for some reason.
You drive rush, crouch and leg punch, okay.
Good.
Ah, okay.
She's getting thrown.
I don't even know who I know.
Yeah, be really careful about Super.
They try and beat the Super.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
There we go.
All right All right one final.
Let's go curry One final.
Let's go curry
Let's go I'm glad I'm not lazy right now Come on, let's go curry
That's fine.
Oh no.
Does he feel that?
No.
It's so scary when you're like trying to figure out the kills.
Let's go.
One more.
Come on.
All right.
One more.
Let's go.
Nice.
Watch out for the driver.
They won't expect it the third time.
Oh, he didn't.
He actually expected it for the third time.
It's okay.
Let's do one more hit.
He level three.
Let's go!
We going to Japan?
Oh my god!
Wait, is that it?
Is that it?
Are we going to Japan?
Oh my god!
See you all in Japan!
He did it!
You did it!
Oh my god, I'm about to try, bro.
Oh my god, that was the most intense fight.
Bro, I think I would put you on a third set.
Like, you needed three.
You needed all six matches.
The manager you get the clutch today is absolutely absurd.
You are insane.
my god bro i'm literally about to cry i'm i'm so hungry i get hot pot let's go there's no way i can't believe we won i can't believe it oh congratulations everyone oh my god everyone it and it's like it's also like every point really mattered as well like it's a good team effort because we need the home oh but i i was not watching half of those memes i could not watch i was it was feisty clutching doki the round before that also locking in i don't know you just like ascended to a new level with the honda yeah like my third i flipped back to what her original form was bro no my tummy was hurting during that too i was like I'm not locked in but yet somehow it worked oh my god bro that was nuts cheese guys we all did so well I'm so surprised I lost I think six times versus JP if I was actually oh yeah you know I'm glad I'm not you I don't want to we should have a show match to end it up I want to see your nephew versus item yeah nephew versus item I okay I'm gonna demand it i demand a
show match of the coaches i can't believe it i can't believe my eyes bro i feel like i'm i don't know that's insane that's crazy i'm glad we feisty was the one that ended the entire tournament oh yeah that was such a good end yeah yeah i knew yeah that if i won against karki with a defunct controller would that even be satisfying i think yeah yeah no he got his controller back working oh no
oh that's awkward i thought he got it back yeah he was playing really well bro that guy's a prodigy what the heck he instantly knew how to use the ps5 controller yeah that's insane what He played on your pad before, like in our first stage of the upside that I played with him,
he was in your pad.
Oh, that's why I was going to say, did he pick that up instantly?
Like in just like 30 minutes, he just learned how to play.
Oh, man.
Oh, my God, bro.
I'm just in a shock.
I feel like I can't believe it.
You know, you know what I was doing while I was, I was muted.
I was saying, let's go Curry, like doing the Justin jinx on him.
And it worked.
It worked every time I said, let's go, Curry.
Like, he lost.
I was like, all right, I'm going to keep doing that.
Dude, I thought it was over, bro.
I thought it was over.
I was so tired.
Me too.
Bro, we've been streaming.
I mean, I started at the exact not determined start, but we've been streaming for almost eight hours.
Yeah, you don't usually stream that long, right?
No.
Unless it's rivals.
And I can stream for, like, 30 hours.
FGC like fighting games take too much brain power and like my brain does not have that capacity for that name like like after three games I'm like I'm out.
We used up all the battery
Oh GG's everyone GG's I'm so happy.
Yeah, what do we do?
Do we do the show match?
Is it an interview interview time?
Yeah, is it?
I was thinking about logging.
I don't know.
All right is there in interviews for the winning team i'll write that yeah yeah yeah oh i'm happy oh my god man that was so sad yeah i can't believe we actually won that's not that's nuts me too i was i went in i was like i hope i win one game today oh they said that they said there's no interviews we're free to go oh we're free okay I'm sad we didn't get our show I also wish I would I guess foo me once it's okay next twitch con next I don't know the twitch con at least GG's everyone I'm happy to be part of team defies thank you nephew for drafting us I guess I'll see you guys all in Japan that's crazy yeah see you guys in Japan are you all there yeah all right bye bye everyone you guys are awesome good night Good night,
GG's
GG's Guys, I can't believe we won We won it all I Bro, everyone's like I'm fucking tired I'm like me too man Me too Oh my god We get 1k, bro I'm spending that 1k on the day one in Japan yeah that 1k i'm spending that day one it's gone wait no usd is strong in yet in japan guys i forgot about that the yen is strong
wait no the usd is strong oh my god i almost forgot guys i you know bro i could i have spent so much i forgot about that i'm using that for I'm using that for my Japan trip.
Oh, I'm so glad it's over.
I did not expect to go to the finals and win it all.
Like, everything was going wrong for me.
My tummy was hurting.
I was eepy.
It was the hardest fight of my life.
Oh, oh my.
god seratina was laughing the shit out of me and i was looking at funny memes on twitter like i was like i should have laughed more but i was like i felt like if i lab more it gets too real i'm sorry i'm sorry guys i i felt like i know i should have laughed more instead of looking at funny memes on twitter but i knew if i labbed more it would feel way too real like
yeah yeah i would have tied myself out too yeah i got i just like i don't know you guys notice i don't know um you guys noticed that fight against seratina but like i wasn't thinking i it might look like i was thinking but i was literally like i think this move would be good next i was like maybe this move would work.
I don't know.
Literally.
That was the winning strat.
No, it was very obvious.
Yeah.
Oh, I know I do better when I don't think because they can't predict me.
I was doing the dumbest shit possible.
It works.
Yeah.
Oh, yet.
Oh, I'm so happy.
Oh, my God.
I'm so happy.
That's true.
Oh, I'm so happy we won, guys.
At least something good happened this week.
I'm so happy something good happened this week, guys.
It's been really stressful.
I literally looked up.
Okay, you know how like my door is the glass door yeah the my door is the glass door i was looking through you know what i come back and i look through like like you know how dad would look through look through uh the door like to be like please let me and i was doing that i was just looking through the glass i was like are we do i need to come back yet do i and it was always so close and i just and i was like okay the mattress are still going i go back to my bed and just lay down yeah yeah and I come back and I was looking through the glass and I was like,
do I come in?
Oh,
man.
Oh, my God.
My brain is so tight.
My tummy hurts, man.
I, my, my tummy hurt, man.
Oh, I feel bad for the East Coasters.
um we're the east coasters that have to like on on everyone's teams and oh yeah the people who are doing the stage i'm slap they have to do stage i'm slam right tomorrow straight away bro i feel bad for fumi she's on 2x ko isn't she bro she has to go straight to 2x ko right like on the neck just to do the finals tomorrow bro oh my god yeah oh my god poor fumi yeah oh my god i don't guess I have to do the Apex one,
but like that's hot and sick.
It's for charity.
So it's like if I don't kill anyone, I'm the seeker.
So I'm like, no, but thing is, it's just a for fun tournament.
So I'm just like, I don't really care about it too much because like it's just for fun and it's for charity.
So like I'm the seeker too.
So yeah, but SK wasn't in the semi, like the finals.
So like they clocked out after, you know, they've got in semis and it clocked up.
But we have like, was in is in 2x ko and she made it to the finals so like yeah i'm just like i just have to shoot people because like for the hide and see because i'm a seeker i mean it would be great better if i was a hider so i could just i could just chill i have to actually shoot people so um in apex same apex by the way oh my god uh yeah i'm just i'm just glad i'm just glad i i i won i i i think if i had another day playing honda i think i it would be illegal for me in tier one like in the baby tier i i learned way too fast even i was like no i learned way too fast on Honda.
I think like Honda was like it like unlocked my third eye.
Yeah.
That's what.
So I'm just like because like I saw people were like how the heck is she in baby tier when she's flat?
I was like please I swear to God I play silver.
I was like guys I swear to God I started learning three days ago on honda yeah no i i learned honda faster than i learned gif because gif is such a zan gif is such a passive play style when you get to higher elo so like um um but the higher by higher elo i meant silver four because i i was hard to suck silver four on zan gif for so long and i played rank a lot and then i gave up and just was like and i started making custom rooms because um um I started making custom runes because I was hard stuck.
I was hard stuck Silver 4 on Zangief because my aggressive playstyle was not working in Silver 4.
I had to play passive.
And I was like, I don't like that.
I was like, I don't like that.
And thank God, people at the Seijan Slam, they did not.
They did not like realize that I was not passive on Zangief because, you know, Zangief played tend to be super passive until they like tend to be like play really passive and patiently but I was just like no no no oh yeah I'm so happy guys I do adrenaline I'm no longer EP yeah and I started blocking too I started I had to I did you not see what Aki was doing like I had to start blocking it was the only way to punish it I was like not today not today today oh i was i'm happy that um saratina started playing more aggressively because i stopped engaging did you see that she like she started playing because i was like i ain't playing your game and i just stopped i stopped moving like bro i was like you're first because the timer's on my side
That's right.
Justin would be so proud of me.
Oh my god.
Wait, I want to message Big Bird and be like, I won.
I won.
All my matches.
Big Bird wouldn't have to know.
I'm lying, but like, he doesn't have to know.
When you stood still, that was aura.
Oh my god.
he's sleeping i'm pretty sure i made the bird family proud
oh all right guys i'm gonna go get hot pot thank you all for watching i hope you guys had a fun time watching um i'm gonna go get hot pot and i'm rewarding myself with hot pot now and yes wow i'm just crazy i'm not did not expect the wind but here we are
Lying on Sesame Street.
Yeah, just a little white lie.
Technically, I won all my matches.
If you talk about the over...
If you think about it, I wasn't specific on...
Like, he could think overall matches, guys.
Like, he doesn't know if...
He thinks, you know, I didn't specify was overall matches or individual matches, you know?
I didn't lie, because I meant overall matches where my team all won together.
Like...
That's all that matters.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and go around to get that blood flow.
If you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
It's not about time, everyone.
Treat yourself because I'm treating myself.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye.
Secret ending.
By treating yourself, you should buy my controller.
You know how you can do to treat yourself?
Why don't you get my pro controller right now?
That's a good way to treat yourself.
Look at that.
Anyway, bye for real.
Treat yourself.
Buy my merch.